bonjour
j'étais avec rode parado qui est un
acteur du film et voilà et qui va
probablement nous rejoindre un peu plus
tard dans la soirée bon voilà on est
ensemble 2h 2h ça fait 120 minutes en
secondes
devant Notre-Dame on s'est dit qu'on
commencerait par ici c'est bon non c'est
magnifique ouais c'est magnifique à
propos de temps d'ailleurs à propos de
deux heures et de 120 minutes
ça me fait penser à l'expression tu sais
on va pas t'attendre sans sept ans
qui est dû à la autant de
autant qu'ils ont mis à construire cette
cathédrale ça vient de là on va pas
t'attendre 107 ans
tout de suite j'ai pensé je dis que j'ai
failli dire ouais on va peut-être pas
passer 107 ans ensemble non plus non et
en fait expression vient de Notre-Dame
d'accord
mourir un gros mourir c'est une question
on va en parler tout à fait en salle de
pire vous êtes content
je suis ravi que le film soit au cinéma
c'est un film qui était à la base un
docu-fiction donc c'est un film un peu
hybride qui a été un travail assez
colossal pour pour nous tous
c'est-à-dire je pense à tout le casting
donc c'est à dire Gilles Cohen Grégory
Fitoussi ben rode paradox il va nous
rejoindre tout à l'heure
annecera
Damien Giraud Francis Renaud enfin il y
avait toute une bande d'acteurs c'était
une vraie belle aventure humaine et on a
deux mois de préparation avec les
équipes du Puy du Fou
on est ravis je voulais commencer par
notre Adam parce que vous faites un film
historique on fait un film historique
voilà ça c'est l'histoire de France
purée dure mais sinon vous étiez il y a
3 ans et demi pendant l'incendie oui
tout à fait j'ai même j'étais en j'ai
même j'ai même je me suis arrêté j'étais
vers hôtel de ville donc j'ai vu les
choses quasiment direct c'était assez
impressionnant c'est drôle que vous
parliez de du film parce que
Notre Dame c'est évidemment penser à
Victor Hugo
le film commence par une phrase de
Victor Hugo parce que Victor Hugo avait
écrit 93 qui est un 93 qui est un
chef-d'oeuvre il y a aussi Balzac et
Dumas qui sont intéressés aux guerres de
Vendée mais donc effectivement Victor
Hugo il a écrit un chef-d'œuvre sur sur
Notre-Dame mais voilà il avait aussi
écrit 93 donc
c'est
un phare Notre-Dame de Paris je pense et
puis c'est quelque chose d'assez
universel enfin pour moi en tout cas ça
me raconte beaucoup beaucoup de choses
je pense que c'est pour ça que il y a 3
ans ça a une résonance pour beaucoup de
gens parce que
ouais c'est des endroits qui qui te font
penser à
l'histoire en général c'est un au-delà
de au-delà de ce que représente le
monument
assez impressionnant
reste autour de Notre-Dame on va vers
l'Institut du monde arabe d'accord on
commence à y aller alors c'est vous qui
m'avez proposé d'aller là-bas ouais moi
c'est un endroit que j'aime beaucoup
l'Institut du monde arabe
tu sais un peu pour les mêmes raisons
pour lesquelles j'aime bien Notre Dame
c'est que c'est des
c'est ce qui fait c'est ce qui fait la
France en fait ce qui fait la France
dans sa diversité dans
dans son rayonnement entre guillemets à
l'international et ça c'est des choses
qui me plaisent beaucoup et c'est drôle
parce que l'Institut du monde arabe j'y
étais il y a deux jours pour un autre
film pour le film de Rachid ami ouais
qui s'appelle pour la France avec Karim
partout je sais pas c'est gentil non non
je fais je fais je fais un
petit truc dans enfin c'est un rôle
plus secondaire dans le film de Rachid
mais c'est un film que je trouve
vraiment
qui est un très beau il faut un film
très sensible je l'ai découvert
avant-hier à l'Institut du Monde donc
c'est rigolo parce que vous jouez dans
des films de culture oui on voit des
cultures très différentes raccro mourir
on est sur une culture catholique pour
la France c'est plutôt l'inverse c'est à
des familles musulmane
il faut voir le film c'est c'est mais
c'est le principe du cinéma c'est la
diversité c'est de raconter des
histoires différentes qui touchent des
gens différents mais finalement
qui permettent aussi un dialogue des
débats enfin pour moi c'est
moi je suis très heureux de pouvoir être
dans des films comme ça qui sont
extrêmement différents
c'est ça que je trouve vraiment
enrichissant dans le cinéma c'est je
pense que c'est pour ces raisons là que
je me suis orienté vers ce vers ce
métier là en ce genre d'histoire et puis
tout le monde nous on a commencé à jouer
à tous de nous suivre sur YouTube
vous pouvez évidemment nous
suivre son je garde mon portable pas
loin et je transmets des questions si on
a
ça je pense qu'ils viennent pour toi ils
viennent pour vous non rien pour vous
non je suis pas de Paris je suis né à
Metz je suis né à Metz c'est peut-être
pour ça aussi que c'est
c'est ces monuments là mon insu du monde
arabe c'est Jean Nouvel Notre-Dame de
Paris comme on disait ça y est ça a été
une construction
c'était un travail ça a duré 107 ans
donc il y a beaucoup beaucoup de gens
qui ont travaillé sur le projet mais
ouais pour moi c'est des c'est des
choses qui ont des
résonances fortes quand on vient de
quand on vient de province à Paris c'est
les voilà c'est les premiers bâtiments
qu'on découvre en fait c'est les
premiers qui nous marquent moi je suis
pas de Paris non plus quand j'arrive je
dis un parisien mais t'es déjà de la
Tour Eiffel
on a fait tout ça on est allé découvrir
ce qui est sympa à Paris c'est ce qu'on
est en train de faire là je trouve c'est
de se balader la nuit dans les rues ça
c'est un truc
moi j'aime bien j'aime beaucoup flâner
j'aime bien me balader j'aime bien
traîner c'est important de traîner faut
savoir faut trouver le temps de traîner
de temps en temps
de Marielle qui disait ça il disait moi
je suis un très noir
je suis en train
on est dans une ville qui est quand même
enfin on a beaucoup de chance de vivre
comme ça qui est encadré et bercé de
l'histoire donc chaque cru quoi pourquoi
vous êtes venu à Paris c'est obligatoire
pour être comédien
je monte à Paris pour réussir j'ai adoré
ce film les animaux j'ai adoré ce film
j'aime beaucoup
grassement l'année dernière au César
mais tant mieux mais
on vient
pour plein de raisons je pense
effectivement c'est quand même plus
difficile de faire ce métier là dans
à dans d'autres dans d'autres villes si
tu vois c'est
voyez je pense comme dans beaucoup de
métiers dans le vôtre c'est la même
chose on est dans un pays où voilà pas
Paris a une place
à une place importante dans le domaine
notamment artistique et culturel c'est
sûr et pas que
mais non c'est drôle on part quand vous
me parlez de
[Musique]
des deux films
moi il y a quand même un point commun
parce que je reviens là-dessus parce que
vous viviez c'est drôle parce que vous
faites deux choses qui sont très très
différentes vous êtes dans moi c'est ce
que j'essaie de faire c'est ce que je
trouve intéressant mais finalement ils
ont des points communs vraiment
hier
pour la France ça sort alors je voudrais
pas dire de bêtises
je crois que c'est lui février
il y a un côté
universel dans les deux dans les deux
films je trouve qu'on
à mon sens mais c'est je pense le but de
toute histoire en général elle devient
intéressante si on peut s'identifier si
on arrive à se mettre à la place des
personnages entre guillemets et
c'est ce que je voulais dire par
l'Institut du monde arabe comme comme
notre âme c'est des ils ont une
résonance on peut on peut y voir
chacun quelque chose qui est très
différent c'est quelque chose qui c'est
un endroit qui peut vous plaire
simplement parce que c'est un parce que
la bâtisse est belle ou alors parce que
la symbolique est belle peut-être parce
que
culturellement ou socialement
religieusement ça vous touche il y a
plein de il y a plein de choses comme ça
qui peuvent avoir enfin qui peuvent
faire sens pour vous dans un film comme
pour la France ou dans un film comme
vaincre mourir moi ce que ce que ce que
j'aime dans un commentaire notamment
c'est c'est
c'est que finalement on a tous une quête
quelle qu'elle soit où on a tous des
rêves des ambitions des idéaux etc et là
on suit un personnage qui va être
combattif engagé
déterminer pour sa cause mais finalement
on peut s'identifier nous pour une cause
qui est tout autre un peu comme quand
vous regardez
Star Wars ou bref
c'est toujours la même histoire même
Astérix
il y en a beaucoup il y en a beaucoup
mais
en tout cas donc pour la France je
trouve que il est plein de finesse et
finalement moi je me suis beaucoup
identifié alors que il y a des choses
que voilà pourriez-vous enfin
j'ai pas du tout vécu cette histoire là
pour autant
c'est l'histoire de deux frères
une histoire de frère
et notamment en fait c'est l'histoire
c'est une histoire qui est enfin c'est
l'histoire de la vie du réalisateur en
fait
de décidément ils veulent vraiment ils
veulent vraiment
sûr mais c'est des films qui sont
compliqués à
pitcher comme ça en deux secondes mais
il raconte il raconte ce qui est arrivé
à son frère quand il était à Saint-Cyr
et je vous invite vraiment à voir la
bande-annonce plutôt que moi je raconte
parce que et aller le voir parce que
c'est c'est
tellement complexe que c'est pareil
c'est pas du tout c'est pas du tout un
film maniché c'est pas du tout un film
qui qui veut apporter une vision je
trouve que c'est c'est incroyable de
voir à quel point dans ce film je trouve
qu'il a il a réussi ça à pas enfin c'est
c'est
c'est un film du coup sensible et
poignant mais mais pas
est-ce qu'on vous dit pas quoi penser
exactement vous dit pas quoi penser
exactement je crois que c'est moi c'est
ce que j'aime aussi dans un coup mourir
pour moi c'est pas des films
vous savez je pense que
quand on voit un film chacun le regarde
avec c'est avec ses yeux avec son gars
avec son vécu etc il faut respecter ce
que ce que chacun peut en penser
mais ce qui est certain c'est que les
démarches des réalisateurs ou des
auteurs c'est souvent pas ça c'est
souvent au contraire de vouloir créer un
dialogue de vouloir créer un débat mais
mais un débat apaisé c'est ça le
principe du cinéma au moins c'est pour
ça que que je fais ce métier là c'est ça
qui me plaît là-dedans
et je trouve que dans ces deux films là
la volonté c'est justement comme je
disais de d'essayer de trouver quelque
chose d'universel de trouver quelque
chose qui va parler à tout un chacun il
va pouvoir s'identifier et comprendre
le sentiment le sentiment et les
émotions de la personne la personne qui
a du personnage
typiquement comme je disais voilà il y a
des phrases dans un groupe mourir qu'on
pourrait s'appliquer à soi-même dans des
dans la vie de tous les jours dans les
on traverse tous des épreuves des
moments difficiles
quand il dit combat tu sais enfin ça
devise qui est combattu souvent battu
parfois abattu jamais c'est des phrases
qu'on peut appliquer dans d'autres
situations dans d'autres époques
vestiaires de sport ça mais exactement
exactement
les valeurs de de combativité de
dépassement de soi de effectivement moi
c'est des choses que j'aime bien parce
que je trouve que quand j'étais ado
c'était ce que j'adorais c'était ce qui
me faisait vraiment du bien de de voir
des personnages comme ça à l'écran qui
me donnait de la force en fait qui me
donnait de l'espoir qui me donnait envie
de me battre pour et je pense que le
cinéma c'est aussi c'est transmettre des
émotions au-delà de
l'émotion avant l'idée
j'ai envie de dire que c'est l'un ne va
pas sans l'autre mais
typiquement quand on regarde brivart
est-ce que est-ce que est-ce qu'on se
contient le plus c'est l'Écosse et
l'Angleterre ou c'est la combativité de
du personnage de William Wallace
moi je trouve ce personnage moi il me
donne de la force
je pense que je pense que finalement
contrairement à ce qu'on pense c'est oui
c'est quand même beaucoup des émotions
d'abord qui permettent de toucher les
gens et du coup
ensuite de parler d'un sujet
effectivement mais c'est
ça dont on a besoin dans la vie de tous
les jours si on avait pas d'émotion
honnêtement puisqu'il reste pas grand
chose
neutre ouais c'est non mais c'est vrai
on a besoin de ça pour fonctionner pour
avancer dans dans nos projets dans nos
rêves dans voilà dans nos vies à tous
alors je vous ai trouvé très bon j'ai
trouvé très très bon on vous entend tout
le monde du film mais alors c'est
bizarrement fait ce film parce que vous
êtes une voix off
omnipotente on vous entend quasiment à
tous les plans c'était pas censé être un
film à la base c'était un c'était un
docu-fiction à la base qui est donc qui
est un film assez hybride effectivement
après
je suis dans un film je suis dans un
documentaire je suis dans Je c'est vrai
que c'est troublant
comment comment je dois l'interpréter
bah c'est à vous c'est à vous de
l'interpréter comme comme vous le
souhaitez est-ce que ça vous a plu à la
fin bien sûr
et puis vous avez une voix en plus on
vous parle souvent de cette voie c'est
pour ça qu'on vous a plu non et à la fin
il y a un petit frisson j'admets
j'admets
si ça vous a plu je pense que cette
forme qui est un peu hybride ça prouve
c'est aussi c'est aussi simple cinéma
c'est tenter des choses c'est d'avoir le
courage de tenter quelque chose de
différent de prendre un peu des risques
de pas faire tout le temps exactement la
même chose
moi je trouve que c'est c'est quelque
part de la part des réalisateurs et des
équipes techniques ça c'est c'est une
promesse d'avoir réussi
avec 3,5 millions d'euros à faire un
film comme ça c'est 3 millions et demi
d'euros les enfants ne le savent pas
c'est rien pour faire un film hein c'est
très c'est très peu c'est ce qu'on
défile oui des petits films
Astérix qui sort la semaine prochaine 65
millions voilà voilà c'est un bon
exemple
oui ça vous a plu ça vous a parlé vous
avez ressenti des choses alors qu'il y a
un format qui est un peu hybride moi
j'ai l'impression aussi que le film
il y a effectivement cette voix qui est
présente mais au fur et à mesure du film
elle est de moins en moins si vous
faites attention on est de plus en plus
peut-être on est de plus en plus dans
je trouve que ça donne un côté aussi où
on s'attache à la vie intérieure du
personnage ça permet d'être avec lui
dans sa tête c'est un choix encore une
fois de ressenti
là par exemple il vous filme
merci merci pauvre Sylvain
[Rires]
si vous en prenez un mois et que vous
êtes interview vous plaît pas c'est moi
qui prend non mais en il y a vraiment ce
cette chose là de
d'avoir
d'être dans la tête du personnage ça
permet forcément un ressenti qui est
différent si Sylvain vient vous filmer
ici
c'est pas ampleur beaucoup dans une
série que j'ai faite qui s'appelle Baron
Noir où le personnage principal est très
souvent filmé à l'épaule ou
je veux dire en profil perdu enfin on
est vraiment dans des trois quarts dans
les trois quarts de profils ça nous
permet d'être vraiment dans sa tête
dans un coup mourir ou vous êtes sur la
cheminée comme ça très proche vers la
fin c'est un peu ça l'idée
c'est à dire vous êtes vous êtes sur la
cheminée et c'est vrai que l'émotion est
très différente parce que vous êtes deux
dessous le plan énorme sur votre visage
et en effet là le point de vue change
complètement par rapport à la diffusion
ce qui est intéressant c'est que déjà
vous vous rappelez de la scène ça c'est
ça c'est ça
en tout cas
en tout cas je vois là je trouve que
c'est un film original
atypique avant ça moi j'avais fait un
signe qui s'appelle le dernier voyage
qui est un film de science-fiction avec
avec Jean Reno qui avait voilà
j'avais très clairement une portée
écologique mais assume c'est pour ça
enfin moi c'est un film qui faisait sens
c'était très heureux que ce soit mon
premier rôle au cinéma le premier la
première fois que j'avais un premier
rôle aussi voilà exactement
c'était beaucoup battu avec le
réalisateur pour le faire d'ailleurs il
sort un autre film romain qui s'appelle
Apache dans quel
je fais un personnage qui s'appelle
Beloeil qui est qui est un peu le
méchant du film et c'est c'est un petit
clin d'oeil parce que voilà on s'entend
très bien
je n'ai pas encore vu donc je peux pas
vous je peux pas trop en parler mais en
tout cas c'est une proposition un peu
originale c'était pour dire que le ouh
là Sylvain ça va
l'utilisateur ça c'était même pas vu
mais non non c'est vrai que le
dernier voyage c'était un film de la
même façon qui était c'était très très
très difficile à monter parce que un
film de science-fiction en France il y
en a assez peu tout comme pas du tout
voilà et pourtant
romain a réussi à le faire il a il a
gagné un Méliès d'argent à Sitges il a
voilà et ça a été un combat de trois ans
et c'est bien de faire des enfin moi
j'étais très heureux qu'on fasse un film
comme ça qui
essaye d'ouvrir des portes en fait parce
que le cinéma on a une chance inouïe en
France d'avoir un cinéma qui est très
divers
[Applaudissements]
moi je pense que ça va quand même la
preuve la Babylone est sortie qui est je
suis allé voir qui est moi j'ai beaucoup
aimé qui aimerait une vraie déclaration
aussi d'amour un peu au cinéma
il fait un très gros score
aux États-Unis et il marche en France je
pense qu'en France il y a beaucoup plus
de curieux de gens curieux qui ont il y
a une culture de il y a une culture de
l'esprit critique de la liberté
d'expression de la liberté de conscience
et donc c'est ce qui fait que les gens
s'intéressent énormément je trouve en
France à beaucoup de sujets qui vont au
cinéma et qui vont au théâtre qui vont
et typiquement le dernier voyage c'est
un film qui a fonctionné
il y a beaucoup de gens qui avaient
envie en fait de voir un film de
science-fiction français qui soit pas
forcément comme un film américain qui va
avoir attendu voilà exactement qui va
avoir un côté il a un côté très poétique
ce film donc très différent
finalement d'une approche américaine
mais voilà ça a beaucoup ça a beaucoup
plu au final un certain public
vaincre mourir faire un film historique
c'est pareil il y a un vrai il y a un
vrai con il y a un vrai combat de faire
des films comme ça parce que des films
historiques c'est très très rare en
France parce que voilà il faut des
centaines de figurants il faut que les
acteurs s'entraînent il faut voilà il
faut il faut les préparer pendant un
mois ou deux en fait la cascade
vous avez fait la série Diane de
Poitiers vous êtes oui c'est ça
de Poitiers à monter à cheval
effectivement et
et grâce à vaincre mourir j'ai pu me
perfectionner voilà et j'ai eu deux mois
de véritables entraînement grâce à ça
j'ai pu faire un ensemble de mes
cascades comme tous les acteurs du film
d'ailleurs tout le monde fait tout le
monde fait ses cascades il y a eu un
mois et demi deux mois de de préparation
ce qui est quand même c'est quand même
beaucoup voilà c'est pas toujours comme
ça et pour le film de Romain c'est
pareil on s'était extrêmement préparé en
amont quand il y a des budgets qui sont
plus faibles
comme on va avoir moins de temps de
tournage
on compense en général par beaucoup de
travail en amont enfin en tout cas c'est
ce qu'il faut faire oui parce que quand
vous arrivez il faut être tout de suite
prêt parce qu'il y a pas exactement il
faut il faut penser à autre chose en
amont et préparer le plus possible on va
parler de la polémique à un moment vous
savez où c'est vrai que j'ai quand même
ça m'amuse de faire ça j'ai fait un film
qui s'appelle la nuit juste dans les
forêts
un flash de alors je l'ai pas vu
d'accord j'essaie de le retrouver en
streaming j'avoue il y a la Cinémathèque
il est sur la plateforme de la
Cinémathèque française vous faites une
heure et demie en plan séquence 1h39 en
plein séquence ouais vraiment
fréquences
[Musique]
ce sont des faux plan séquence avec des
raccords etc il y a des volets
une seule caméra on nous suit on suit
dans les rues de en fait c'est la nuit
juste avant les forêts c'est une de
Bernard marie-coltès qui est un auteur
de Metz c'est un auteur de théâtre très
très connu mais il est de messe
d'ailleurs c'est assez drôle parce que
souvent dans ces pièces les gens ne
savent pas mais ces personnages ont des
noms de rue de Metz moi je suis de Metz
elle avait joué cette pièce là à l'Opéra
Théâtre là-bas et cette pièce est ma
marquée c'est une pièce sur un sans-abri
qui traîne d'ailleurs
mais qui qui a fait le monde qui ont
révolte contre tout qui voudraient
changer le monde qui essaie de trouver
une façon
d'imaginer comment qu'est-ce qu'on
pourrait créer alors il veut pas faire
politique il veut pas faire de syndicat
il veut pas faire
il est contre tout et finalement mais
mais il a envie d'aider les plus faibles
et plus démunis c'est c'est voilà dont
il fait partie et il en veut à tout le
monde mais en fait on se rend compte au
fur et à mesure du film qui s'en veut
surtout à lui-même
et ce personnage là finit par avoir
envie de créer finalement et de créer un
syndic le syndicat international un
syndicat international c'est son grand
truc c'est très drôle parce qu'il se
contredit totalement en fait il fait que
ce contredire tout au long de la
politique finalement mais en fait pas
vraiment
il faut voir là il faut voir la pièce
mais il veut pas mais finalement il voit
bien que la seule façon de protéger des
gens c'est c'est trouver un endroit qui
ils ont un refuge
et bref on a fait cette pièce moi
m'avait troublé énormément
à la lecture et quand je l'ai quand je
l'ai joué et on a décidé d'en faire un
plan séquence mais on a vraiment fait
pour pour le faire c'était pour la
beauté du geste entre guillemets on
avait aucune
heure 39 de texte donc c'est une phrase
qui ne s'arrête pas cette pièce cette
pièce c'est une phrase donc une question
jusqu'à la fin vous êtes capable
non non mais ouais il y a il y a un truc
comme ça très
dans cette pièce qui est très
atypique surprenant mais c'est une pièce
violente en même temps c'est vraiment
une pièce violente parce qu'on est on se
rend compte de ce que c'est que la vie
d'un essai pour compte c'est quoi sa vie
c'est quoi son quotidien qu'est-ce qui
se passe dans sa tête pendant voilà et
pendant une heure et demie on est avec
lui et on comprend ces digressions on
finit par comprendre c'est pertes de
repères ce qui se perd tout le temps
dans son discours et donc moi c'est ça
m'avait énormément touché évidemment
c'est pas une comète évidemment c'est
pas une comédie et en fait on l'a fait
en plan séquence comme je vous disais
pour le pour le faire parce qu'on
voulait qu'il en reste quelque chose
et on n'était même pas sûr de réussir à
le faire pour être toute la fenêtre on
l'a fait en se disant si ça se trouve on
va tourner mais on va pas réussir parce
que là dans un plan séquence comme ça au
bout d'une heure 20 vous plantez ah bah
c'est foutu c'est foutu et il faut
savoir que les conséquence se fait dans
les bus dans dans
des bas on vit avec le
mais mais ouais c'était c'était très
particulier on l'a tourné plusieurs
jours on l'a tourné plusieurs jours
parce qu'on a dû le faire pas mal de
fois parce que vous l'avez vous l'avez
raté évidemment on l'a raté
on a raté plusieurs fois on l'a raté
bien ou quoi parce que il y avait
tellement d'imprévus dire qu'on était
c'est un film qu'on a fait 100 sans
budget qu'on a fait des passionnés
c'est dans le film ou alors c'est foutu
on refait mais parfois il peut même y
avoir des des problèmes plus
il faut des autorisations de tournage et
là on a un petit peu fait de façon
anarchique donc mais à l'image du
personnage du personnage mais en même
temps je crois que la démarche a
beaucoup plu à on a eu on a eu
on a eu la Cinémathèque qui nous a
offert une carte blanche donc c'était
Costa garage qui nous a offert une carte
blanche c'était génial et la salle la
projection passe la projection avait
avait bien fonctionné et ensuite ils
nous ont proposé de mettre le film sur
la plateforme de la Cinémathèque la
plateforme ils ont une plateforme de
streaming comme Netflix qui s'appelle
Henri
si vous voulez le voir c'est c'est sur
la plateforme Henri la Cinémathèque et
pendant le confinement ça ils l'ont
laissé parce que ça ça a été extrêmement
regardé moi j'étais j'étais un peu
j'étais un peu abasourdi de ça parce que
c'était vraiment quelque chose qu'on a
fait
pas du tout dans une optique
évidemment pas commercial ça c'est
certain mais en plus de ça il y avait un
côté oui effectivement mais il y avait
un côté on le faisait on verra sans se
dire
comme ça mais moi
je trouve que le c'est ça qui est ça qui
est le plus amusant c'est ça qui est le
plus marrant en fait dans les films
c'est de faire des choses
qu'on ferait pas dans la vie honnêtement
je pense qu'on oublie tous mais c'est un
truc de gamme ah mais c'est un rêve
d'enfants
et c'est vrai que c'est les trois films
dont on vient de parler à les forêts
comme le dernier voyage ou c'est un
astronaute fugitif dans un monde
post-apocalyptique
ou vaincre mourir
en général vendéen pendant pendant les
guerres de Vendée c'est c'est
c'est des rêves d'enfants ces
personnages là c'est des personnages
[Musique]
vous mettez ah non c'est surtout Twitter
vous mettez tous vos
titres en bio ouais en bio alors je le
retrouve ici Hugo Becker
pour montrer tous les rôles que vous
avez dans votre vie
c'est aussi pour dire que en fait
plus tôt avocat agent secret Flick un
filtré au pays du flamenco député Zuko
tueur en série donc
[Rires]
en fait c'est c'est choisi ces métiers
là pour vivre plusieurs vies c'est ça
qui est amusant donc là c'est un peu un
pied de nez pour un acteur en fait
définir oui exactement ouais un petit
ouais
d'un des autres j'imagine il y a des
rôles qui sont plus prenant que d'autres
c'est assez facilement
au théâtre en fait on répète tellement
tellement le texte et moi je le fais de
plus en plus même au cinéma en amont
parce que je trouve c'est extrêmement
utile on a une maîtrise totale de ce
qu'on fait et on trouve des choses sur
le personnage en fait à retravailler une
scène énormément en amont on trouve des
choses et au théâtre effectivement comme
au cinéma si on répète beaucoup les
mêmes scènes au bout d'un moment le
texte
est infuser il est infusé en vous c'est
un peu étrange
cette sensation vous avez un mot que
vous répétez 10 fois et d'un seul coup
il perd son sens est-ce que ça
on va le répéter 100 fois et
plus il y a un moment il va prendre une
autre dimension va se dire ah ok c'était
ça et on a trouvé l'élément déclencheur
qui qui va nous donner un parfum un
chemin sur plein d'autres aspects du
personnage sur justement sur une phrase
qu'on s'est répétée
c'était le cas pour la nuit juste avant
les forêts ça je l'ai vraiment appris
sur la nu juste avant les forêts c'était
le
je pensais être incapable de connaître
l'ensemble du texte c'est un livre tu
dois apprendre un livre
à l'école c'était de la difficile
c'était trop vert
il y a un côté où on se rend compte dans
la mémoire c'est un muscle donc si on si
on l'entraîne mais
on se rend compte que à force de
travailler un texte finalement tout
devient au bout d'un moment évident
c'est très étrange comme sensation on
peut le comprendre que si on est
uniquement si on le fait on a tellement
travaillé ce texte là il est tellement
ancré en nous que finalement on il
s'agit uniquement de se faire confiance
et se dire de ne pas penser justement de
ne pas penser de se perdre dans le début
de la situation dans quel personnage est
plongé et tout prend sens et tout
démarre et c'est c'est
assez fou comme donc je sais pas si
c'est de la schizophrénie je pense pas
mais en tout cas c'est quelque chose de
très spécifique à notre métier c'est
peut-être pour ça moi c'est ce qui
m'amuse c'est effectivement j'ai choisi
ce métier là parce que je voulais pas
choisir dans la vie je voulais pas faire
un truc je j'avais envie de vivre
plusieurs vie au moins d'avoir
l'illusion de vivre plusieurs envie mais
si on y croit vraiment on les vit on les
vit puisqu'on se prépare quand on se
prépare pour vaincre mourir qu'on fait
deux mois de cascade d'escrime et
d'équitation
en tout cas on est des on est dans des
décors naturels et on apprend des choses
qu'on n'aurait pas appris si on faisait
pas ce métier là ça c'est sûr on discute
c'est pas su
c'est un pose le silence
ces gens nouvelles c'est ça
mais oui c'est vrai que c'est drôle de
se faire suivre comme ça par Sylvain ça
me rappelle ce plan séquence de la nuit
exactement il faut l'oublier mais ça me
rappelle ah bonjour bonsoir
enchanté
général de l'imma d'accord merci
infiniment de nous recevoir c'est très
simple d'ouvrir les
[Musique]
240 boucharabie sont éclairés
et puis j'ai l'impression de poursuivre
un dialogue qui a commencé il y a deux
jours puisqu'on a fait la projection
avant-première exactement la France de
Rachid Ali donc votre voix a déjà
pénétré ensemble
allez on y va alors merci beaucoup je
vous en prie
on est bien
d'accord
[Musique]
on en parlait tout à l'heure je trouve
qu'il y a quelques bâtiments à Paris qui
raconte vraiment
masquer le en tout cas enfin moi ce que
ce que j'aime dans notre pays c'est à
dire son son ouverture d'esprit et son
voilà il y a un rayonnement c'est
extrêmement
le bobo du monde arabe entre guillemets
et je me rappelle j'étais vu je crois en
2016 ou 2017 il y avait un
et quelques années peut-être je me
trompe de date mais c'était sur les
aventuriers
Marco Polo
près de 200 personnes tout à l'heure
présentation d'ouvrage sur sur la
situation politique de la Syrie et la
guerre civile et les
totalitarisme qui met en place par la
famille Assad et ce qui est assez rare
c'est que la soirée s'est poursuivi par
des lectures de textes et là il doit
être 22h30 la soirée a commencé à 19h30
c'est génial
on a vécu un moment tout à l'heure qui
était assez bouleversant de lecture de
texte de remise en contexte de la
situation politique de la Syrie non mais
c'est c'est des lieux extrêmement
importants assez extrêmement important
d'avoir des lieux comme ça je trouve
pour pour les gens pour la pour nos pays
enfin moi c'est pour ça que j'adore ce
cet endroit là comme comme il y a
beaucoup d'autres endroits mais celui-ci
faut qu'on mesure pas toujours la chance
qu'on a d'avoir des des endroits comme
ça et puis voilà je trouve ça fait pour
moi c'est
avant-hier c'est
ce qui fait là voilà enfin pour moi
c'est ça là c'est aussi ça la France
quoi c'est ça qui est génial parce qu'il
y a pas beaucoup de pays où on a on a
accès
à autant de choses et autant de fenêtres
sur sur les autres pays quoi c'est vrai
et puis en plus au-delà de ça notre pays
lui-même il est fait de ça c'est
moi je trouve ça absolument génial voilà
donc bravo pour ce que vous faites ici
aux côtés de Jack Lang qui préside
institut et il a pour habitude de dire
que la société française c'est une
société de métissée et l'Institut du
monde arabe il a vocation à valoriser ce
métissage des cultures qui qui ont fait
notre pays c'est ça c'est à dire que
c'est c'est la diversité c'est ce qu'a
dit j'ai beaucoup aimé ce qui avait dit
Omar Sy à propos de me disait c'est la
somme de tous les récits qui fait notre
histoire commune il a dit dans un
contexte etc pour par rapport à son film
mais au-delà de ça cette phrase je
trouve qu'elle est très juste et ce
genre d'endroit c'est ce qui permet ça
parce que c'est vrai qu'on a une société
extrêmement
diverses et métissé et
et voilà et c'est bien c'est bien qui
est des endroits qui symbolisent ça et
qui racontent ça aussi concrètement en
fait qui deviennent des des métaphores
concrètes
on a plusieurs expositions en ce moment
on a plusieurs événements on en a une
qui s'appelle Habibi révolution de
l'amour 23 artistes LGBT issus de mon
arabe Bahia une artiste algérienne de la
seconde partie du 20e siècle totalement
Todd et on a cette exposition sur
l'histoire de l'Ouzbékistan fin 19e
début 20e siècle à travers les trésors
12kistan qui sont la 350 rue 1300 pièces
qui vont jamais sorti qui sont jamais
sortis c'est pour la première fois pour
les présente
orbeezkistan et peut-être la dernière
donc c'est
en fait une on a une visite
vous allez voir avant ça un petit peu je
suis venu hier
mais c'est souvent
arabe parce que alors là c'est pas loin
d'arabe mais c'est un point d'appui pour
notre aussi le métissage des cultures
l'Ouzbékistan c'est les grands noms
peut-être un jour un de ces personnages
parce que c'est déjà viscan c'est
Alexandre le Grand c'est ta merlan c'est
des figures qui ont marqué les
imaginaires et les imaginaires
planétaires je veux dire à l'échelle
mondiale et là cette exposition tant à
montrer les intrications entre toutes
ces cultures Ouzbékistan c'est vraiment
la transoxane comme on l'a entendu une
terre de mélange de culture qui a été
traversé par des grandes peuplates des
grandes civilisations la civilisation à
kemini Perse en passant par les peuplats
de nomades des Mongols avec l'occupation
de James Khan Alexandre le Grand a
occupé aussi le l'espace de
l'Ouzbékistan
d'autres empires l'empire perse qu'il y
a laissé notamment la philosophie
soroastrienne les Arabes ont pu partir
du 8ème siècle
ils ont implanté la religion musulmane
Ouzbékistan est aujourd'hui en Italie
mais la région musulmane et la première
religion du pays et là ce qu'on voit à
travers des tissus vous avez toute une
série de ce qu'on appelle des chapans
qui sont des des manteaux
richement ornés doté qui était porté
plutôt par soit le alors la ligne de
Boukhara ses proches des grands
dignitaires il faut aussi imaginer que
dans certaines occasions vous aviez des
des personnalités qui portaient jusqu'à
7 chapanes un sur les autres les uns sur
les autres
ça donne chaud
alors ça va mieux il fait bon ici
c'est très très beau chapanes voilà donc
ça c'est les espèces de de caftan
vous avez différents styles vous avez
principalement trois styles là vous avez
le style de cours qui qui est notamment
si vous portez par par les familles de
limir
et puis vous avez derrière alors toute
une codification extrêmement
intéressante sur
n'importe quel champagne c'est ça alors
en fonction de votre statut social en
fonction de votre rang dans le pouvoir
en fonction de votre âge en fonction de
votre sexe vous portez pas les mêmes
habits donc les couleurs sont
différentes notamment pour les femmes
vous avez des couleurs différentes par
tranche d'âge et alors les les chapannes
sont essentiellement fait par des hommes
et notamment lorsqu'on y inclut des
éléments d'or et puisque
traditionnellement seuls les hommes
pouvaient manipuler leur donc ce ne sont
pas les femmes qui donc ce sont des
hommes qui ont fait des chapats
notamment échappants dorés en revanche
les femmes il y avait une espèce de
distribution de division des tâches du
travail les femmes s'occupaient d'autres
attributs d'apparat ce qu'on va voir
après notamment avec les sous-anis qui
sont des pièces d'ornementation qui
étaient qui commençait à être réalisé à
la naissance d'une fille en prévision de
la dot et alors là ce sont des pièces
absolument admirables qui peuvent avoir
plusieurs utilités accrochées à des murs
des dessus de lits recouvrir un individu
etc nappe on va aller voir on y va
parfait
l'admiration parce que le travail qui
doit être enfin qui doit être fait pour
enfin c'est assez impressionnant je suis
pas sûr que je savais tout à fait
capable
de faire mais c'est surtout que c'est
sublime on se tenait c'est vraiment très
très bon j'entends souvent des acteurs
qui disent il y a deux écoles qui disent
moi je ne suis que le transmetteur je
dis ce qu'on dit et voilà et pas plus
parce que un acteur doit être cultivé
doit le dire franchement c'est un
Depardieu dis-moi je viens de nulle part
Châteauroux et en fait j'ai lu et en
fait j'ai appris des plus grands et je
me suis renseigné sur la philosophie la
psychanalyse etc ou est-ce que non c'est
certain comme Belmondo qui dit moi on me
donne un texte et je le joue et je
m'éclate
je pense qu'il y a autant de
autant de gens que de façon
d'appréhender son métier différente mais
moi il me semble nécessaire
de creuser et d'apprendre des choses
constamment c'est ce que je trouve le
plus passionnant dans la vie quelqu'un
de très curieux sans avoir la culture
qui peut l'entourer
si on fait une comédie par exemple je
suis pas sûr que ce soit tout à fait
nécessaire de toute façon il y a pas
grand chose sur le voilà il y a parfois
des films où il y a pas il y a pas
matière à creuser et puis il y a
peut-être même des films où c'est
nécessaire de de pas avoir une approche
trop psychologique ou trop cérébral qui
pourrait abîmer le côté instinctif mais
en général moi je trouve ça mais par
exemple j'ai joué j'ai fait un
footballeur pour les BBC c'était
nécessaire de qui a un travail un
apprentissage mais qui soit pas
théorique mais qui soit physique que
j'ai perdu 7 kg et quelques je suis très
mauvais au foot et du coup j'ai vraiment
entraînement pendant un mois et demi
avec des footballeurs de Charlton j'ai
réussi à faire ce qu'on me demandait
c'est-à-dire mettre une lucarne à un
moment donné il y avait quelque chose
technique que je devais faire moi
c'était nécessaire en revanche est-ce
que je devais pour autant connaître
l'ensemble du monde du football non
c'est pas du tout nécessaire de
connaître le nom des joueurs par exemple
pour bien
et je pense que ce que dit de parler
c'est aussi que le
les films comme les pièces de théâtre
comme les livres etc
c'est des c'est des trésors en fait
c'est des choses qui te donnent accès à
un savoir après à toi d'avoir un esprit
critique de de te dire ok mais ça j'ai
aimé mais je pense que je suis pas tout
à fait d'accord avec si ou ça pour moi
c'est ça donc effectivement quand on
vient
quel que soit le milieu dont on vient
c'est
c'est des choses ce serait dommage de
faire son métier sans jamais
s'intéresser à rien ce que je veux dire
ce serait quand même un peu triste parce
que c'est c'est pas le principe c'est
pas l'idée c'est pas l'idée en tout cas
c'est pas l'idée du septième art non je
pense que l'idée tout comme la
littérature tout comme c'est c'est aussi
c'est aussi de transmettre des choses
qui vont vous faire eux qui par exemple
tu fais ce que je te dis et tu vas pas
plus loin est-ce que vous l'avez déjà
senti ça avec des réalisateurs ah oui ça
peut arriver bien sûr et parfois il peut
avoir raison d'ailleurs parce que ils
ont une vision et ils savent comment
ça c'est deux choses différentes parce
que ces deux choses il y en a un c'est
se mettre aussi la question c'est se
mettre au service d'un texte et d'un
réalisateur la réponse est oui c'est
sinon faut réaliser son film il faut
quand on quand on va sur un film on
n'est pas de réalisateur donc on est au
service tous les acteurs sont au service
d'une histoire que qui racontait d'une
vision après
cette vision elle appartient au
réalisateur en revanche de de passer de
filmer en film sans jamais
avoir la curiosité de de s'intéresser à
ce qui est à ce qui a été la vie telle
ou telle personne ou ou ce que c'est de
vivre dans tel ou tel univers enfin moi
c'est ce que je préfère se préparer pour
un rôle en fait c'est là où tu apprends
plein de choses
quand j'ai fait une une série comme
comme chef j'avais appris la découpe
j'avais appris à vider un sanglier
j'avais appris ça c'est d'ailleurs on va
en parler mais non mais en fait chaque
il y a des choses techniques comme ça
concrètes physiques comme on parle et
puis voilà certaines pièces de théâtre
par exemple quand j'ai fait j'ai fait
Amadeus avec Thierry Frémont il est
évident qu'il faut qu'on s'intéresse un
peu à la musique tu veux pas jouer
Mozart sans sans t'intéresser à rien ce
serait quand même et ce serait triste en
fait ce serait vraiment dommage que
c'est le principe de enfin c'est c'est
le principe d'un d'un projet artistique
c'est c'est de faire découvrir des
choses au public donc
[Musique]
c'est remise à la musique pour
s'imprégner du du rôle de chef
d'orchestre génialissime et j'ai vu dans
le dernier film de pacifiction
d'albertera si vous l'avez vu avec avec
je l'ai pas vu la bonne humeur
c'est un des acteurs préférés alors j'ai
lu qu'il avait un méthode de tournage
très très particulier avec trois caméras
pour que le l'acteur ne ne ne ne ne ne
ne ne se concentre pas sur la caméra qui
filme
je sais pas si ça le rapport à la caméra
c'est quelque chose que pour moi c'est
vraiment de choses différentes il y a le
lâcher prise donc le fait de se donner
corps et âme à ce qu'on est en train de
faire au rôle et à ce qu'on nous demande
de faire ça c'est le travail de l'acteur
bien sûr et puis il y a aussi le fait de
s'intéresser en revanche au-delà du
moment où on joue à l'univers dans
lequel on nous a mis enfin moi je sais
que quand j'ai commencé à faire du
théâtre ce qui était passionnant c'était
que tous ces grands textes ils
transmettent énormément de choses on
apprend énormément de choses quand on
travaille des textes donc pour moi c'est
deux trucs c'est deux choses très très
différentes c'est-à-dire que on peut
très bien lâcher prise complètement et
se mettre au service de la vision de
quelqu'un et pour autant
lire se renseigner avoir un esprit
critique voilà et après on se met malgré
tout au service de sa vision mais on le
on revient à la phrase de Marcy mais un
récit ou une façon de faire
un film par exemple un livre
ça annule pas un autre livre ou une
autre vision est-ce qu'on pourrait très
bien parce que par exemple vous jouez
vous jouez dans la chute le film où vous
jouez dans la vague est une préférée la
vague sublime film
en fonction du rôle que vous avez vous
êtes vous n'êtes pas forcé de de d'aimer
tel ou telle personnage mais en fait on
s'en fout c'est pas ça qui est
intéressant c'est intéressant c'est le
dialogue et la la réflexion va avoir le
spectateur en regardant le film on fait
pas pour nous en fait on s'en fout de ce
que nous on pense enfin tu vois c'est ça
que tu as deux choses
je parle aussi de gens qu'on mourir
c'est vrai ouais ouais mais je parle
aussi de honnêtement je parle de
beaucoup de choses que j'ai je parle de
bar en noir bah au moins c'était une
série où je trouvais un type de gauche
que vous devez être un type de gauche
pens comme un type de gauche et pas voir
la vision extérieure d'en bas en noir
non ce que je vous donne ce que je
disais par là c'était plutôt moi
j'adorais le rôle que j'ai eu en bas en
noir j'adore j'adore ce qu'il dit
j'adore ce discours de la fin afin de
discours de fin est sublime c'est que ça
a l'air complètement voilà la façon dont
j'envisage de la vie et les choses on
est quand il dit voilà n'oubliez pas le
premier jour vous êtes rentré dans un
local et vous avez dit est-ce que je
peux aider
[Musique]
la vision que tu vas donner par exemple
le personnage de Philippe ringarde dans
Baron Noir si tu n'es pas avec lui dans
sa vie privée qui fait par Kad Merad ou
le personnage de Nissa instrument si tu
n'es pas avec eux
tu peux très bien faire un film où tu es
de leur côté et un film où tu es en face
et et toi en tant qu'acteur ça c'est pas
important ça c'est ça que je veux dire
c'est pas important toi tu dois faire
ton truc à fond et ça n'empêchera pas
qu'on raconte c'est plus simple vous
voyez on finit par se tutoyer ça fait
une heure qu'on parle ensemble déjà je
rappelle pour ceux qui pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent qu'on est à l'Institut
du monde arabe avec Hugo Becker avec
Jean-Michel Crozes le secrétaire général
on en est où de cette exposition c'est
ce fameux tapis comment vous me dites ça
s'appelle comment alors ça s'appelle des
suzanies et on expose là j'allais dire
de faire des suzanie de deux écoles
différentes l'une de ça marquant des et
l'autre de Boukhara et alors elles ont
chacune leurs propres motifs
inspiré de du zorroastrisme notamment et
de toutes les influences culturelles de
du pays là vous avez l'école des fleurs
donc effectivement vous retrouvez sur
les différents sous anis espèce de
floraison extrêmement luxuriante
coloré chamaré et puis vous avez ensuite
d'autres sujets qui
comme celui-ci
sont représentent des constellations
qui appartiennent voilà à notre école
donc c'est un peu le d'un côté les
jardins d'Eden et de l'autre la Voie
Lactée c'est deux écoles qui se sont
structurées de manière un peu
systématique sur la représentation de du
monde constellaire et de l'autre de
l'espèce de jardin onirique
et alors évidemment derrière ce sont des
maîtres artisans
exceptionnels par leur savoir-faire qui
ont atteint un niveau d'excellence
quasiment uniquement ou des femmes alors
là on est plutôt sur sur des femmes qui
peut-être ont envie de changer de voix
peut-être carrière j'ai des doigts
on n'a pas encore ouvert d'atelier mais
on peut vous confier le l'admission
qu'on met pas au sol alors ça dépend
particulièrement qui est celui-ci qui
date du 20e siècle parce que la laine
est très fragile on a peu de témoignages
plus anciens que fin 19e siècle sur les
tapis donc
il paraît en moins bon état alors
mais ce tapis je le trouvais
exceptionnel parce que par ces motifs il
tend vers l'abstraction pendant on
dirait un tableau de pincement on est
sur faire quelque chose de ça me fait
presque penser à pêche man aussi
on pourrait dire bourgeois par exemple
il y a quelque chose ces araignées comme
ça sur la sur la sur le tapis
quelle période donc là on est moitié 20e
siècle donc c'est c'est un tapis qui est
relativement récent on est sur des
matières très fragiles avec des états de
conservation 20e siècle 19ème siècle qui
était quand même assez limité
les notions de conservation quand même
plus tardive
et d'ailleurs pour la conservation de
tout ce que vous avez ici le est-ce que
le fait de tout exposer les visites etc
c'est pas
j'imagine que c'est quelque chose qui va
vous préoccuper c'est pas assez me
préoccupation non j'imagine de de
conserver enfin que ça que les choses ne
s'abîment pas se détériorent pas
la question en les faisant venir aussi
alors ça c'est une des grandes questions
d'abord les conditions de transport sont
drastiques c'est la première fois que
c'est ces pièces sortent du pays
peut-être la dernière il y a des
négociations par exemple entre les
étapes pour faire sortir des pièces
comme celle-ci alors là où l'espèce
c'est d'abord des discussions qu'on a eu
de fondation à Fondation du Musée là
c'est des pièces qui viennent de d'une
série assez importante de musée à
travers le pays et c'est sous l'eau
patronage je dirais de de des étapes
puisque l'exposition était inaugurée en
présence du président de la République
française et de son homologue ouzbek à
l'occasion d'une visite d'une visite
officielle avec son pendant au Louvre
parce qu'il y a deux expositions sur
l'osbékistan de organiser de concerts et
celle du Louvre témoigne de d'une
décennie de coopération archéologique
avec des équipes du Louvre qui sont
allés sur place en Ouzbékistan pour
travailler dans les fouilles et le
Louvre présente aussi des pièces
extrêmement rares qui ont été restaurées
par les équipes du Louvre et qui traite
d'une plus vaste et qui est antérieure à
celle du 19e siècle en gros du 13e
siècle au 18e siècle alors là vous avez
aussi des pièces qui sont extrêmement
belles si vous avez l'occasion faut y
aller faut aussi aller au musée guidée
j'en profite pour les personnes qui nous
regardent vous avez une exposition sur
la Délégation
archéologique française d'Afghanistan
qui a couvert tout le 20e siècle et vous
retrouvez des similitudes parce que
l'Ouzbékistan touche le parti de
l'Afghanistan et vous retrouvez par
exemple ce qui est très surprenant quand
on connaît mal cette histoire des traits
qu'on voit dans la civilisation Gréco
latine mais précisément parce que vous
avez des
vous avez une occupation grecque la
fameuse civilisation Gréco bactrienne
qui qui sait implanté et qui a apporté
le style lingstick en Ouzbékistan et
donc vous retrouvez des sculptures avec
des visages qui qui sont des visages
évènements qu'on pourrait retrouver
quand vous allez chez pas dans un musée
Athènes ou dans des musées qui traitent
de la période
siècle avant Jésus-Christ c'est très
surprenant alors voyez effectivement des
vous pouvez aussi sonner en date avec
ces différentes influences et c'est là
où on voit effectivement que la question
de métissage elle est vraiment très
particulière en France l'humain on est
un
exactement on voit bien autour de la
Méditerranée toute cette période enfin
toute cette toute cette géographie aussi
de l'Asie de l'Asie centrale à quel
point par la route de la soie évidemment
il y a eu une interpénétration des
cultures des influences des échanges
mutuels parfois par la violence à
travers les conquêtes mais aussi par le
simple échange commercial qui qui s'est
fait au fil du temps et ça me passionne
je trouve ça pas du tout en expert de
l'Ouzbékistan
pour le coup moi je découvre totalement
non non vous voulez Thibault
comme ça parce que effectivement on
n'aurait jamais l'occasion sinon enfin
là en plus on a une visite privée donc
c'est absolument génial mais
on avait privilégié
et alors je fais bien parce qu'il y a un
film qui s'appelle zardos je sais pas si
vous connaissez non raffiné
totalement loufoque et vous retrouverez
les références et qui était le
réalisateur voilà je sais plus
un réalisateur assez connu d'accord
alors là on est dans la dernière partie
faut relever les yeux encore comme
devant le comme devant
et là je dirais on est dans la partie
qui met à la fois la joie les bijoux
ce qu'on appelle la desicates souvent le
nom est lié à la manière de broder à la
manière de tisser et puis on a des alors
quelques tenues notamment de mariage des
coiffes de mariée ici
des
espèces de tunique qui se porte par la
tête et puis alors cette collection de
d'oeuvres picturale qui a été entassé
pendant des années sous-versoviétique
dans des dans des caves
parce que c'est un peu considéré comme
de l'art dégénéré
c'est toute une génération d'avant-garde
russe
qui comme les peintres français du fin
19e 18e siècle ont pris le large
d'accord à l'époque Mathis va au Maroc
par exemple et découvre les couleurs du
sud la rive-sud de la Méditerranée vous
avez des Russes qui qui vont là dans
cette partie
de l'Asie centrale et des coûts des
couleurs extrêmement presque violentes
fortes et ils en font ces tableaux des
portraits
[Musique]
qui qui ensuite vont être cachés voilà
alors vous avez notamment un des grands
leaders de ce mouvement c'est Alexander
volcov ici deux tableaux qui
effectivement
va par exemple on dirait presque un
Atlant c'est c'est extrêmement
moderniste
plein de couleurs géométriques
il y a presque du Kandinsky aussi
et on voit l'imprégnation sur les
peintres de cette époque là qui découvre
cette culture c'est imprégnation des
couleurs des rythmes des formes une
forme de presque de musicalité visuelle
les formes sont presque celles des
habits ici cette sorte donc c'est
celui-ci que je peux éventuellement
garder c'est ça
[Musique]
non mais dans même dans l'entrée je
pense
sur la porte d'entrée
sur la porte d'entrée vous avez
l'habitude d'aller au musée
malheureusement j'aimerais bien
j'aimerais bien collectionner
malheureusement je pense que c'est quand
même réservé à une voilà
il faut que je fasse plus de films
[Rires]
[Musique]
non en fait c'est vraiment les gens avec
qui on travaille c'est travailler en
Espagne aussi avec des Espagnols
et là j'ai peut-être faire un film en
Algérie d'ailleurs j'ai peut-être
apprendre quelques quelques rudiments
d'arabe c'est très très difficile
mais anglais espagnol j'ai eu la chance
mais en fait quand son travail en
Espagne ou en Angleterre aux États-Unis
c'est
c'est vraiment les gens avec qui on
travaille qui font
qui font la différence c'est qu'il y a
vraiment tout c'est la même chose en
fait c'est surtout que c'est l'Europe
donc on est quand même très mais
s'il y a une chose qui est différente
c'est que il y a c'est beaucoup plus
cloisonné sur des grosses productions
américaines c'est un peu plus cloisonné
c'est à dire que le il y a moins de
dialogue chacun à son poste et son rôle
et il y a pas vraiment de dépassement de
poste ce qui a des avantages parce que
il y a une organisation qui est très
huilée etc et en même temps
parfois je pense que c'est aussi un
avantage d'être un peu plus dans
l'artisanat et de pouvoir parler avec
tout le monde et que chacun puisse
rendre service à l'autre sur des sur des
postes voilà et qui pas forcément le
sien mais il se dit bah attends voilà
ils peuvent pas se parler non plus sur
les plateaux américains il est carrément
une distance et pour je pense par souci
d'efficacité mais
moi j'aime bien le côté artisanal aussi
je pense que les deux sont
complémentaires c'est comme quand on
vous dit théâtre est-ce que vous
préférez faire du théâtre ou est-ce que
vous préférez tourner etc c'est
d'éternel question alors que finalement
c'est justement moi ça me paraît évident
que c'est les deux qui étaient
intéressants c'est justement le
complément ça c'est ça qui est qui est
plaisant quoi de pouvoir
de pouvoir travailler du coup on est
enfin à l'étranger comme en France ben
oui c'est j'aurais pas envie de faire un
choix par exemple parce qu'il y a pas il
y a pas un endroit où c'est plus sympa
ou c'est plus intéressant non c'est
vraiment les projets et les gens
un peu comme un peu comme le théâtre et
le cinéma aussi parce que c'est les
metteur en scène qui font
qui font la différence entre
les projets merci beaucoup Jean-Michel
vous nous laissez accéder au toit je
vais vous laisser continuer la visite
on fera un dîner je crois que vous avez
poursuivre avec plaisir
merci beaucoup pour l'instant on reste
un peu en haut allez pas dans le
bâtiment
merci beaucoup à bientôt très sympa ça
vous a plu
aucun problème alors là je suis heureux
il y avait la projection en fait du film
pour la France dans leur ils ont ils ont
une salle de cinéma un instrument arabe
ils ont une salle il y a une
avant-première qui a été faite du film
dans cette salle
qui est d'ailleurs une très belle salle
de cinéma les ah ouais les sublime
c'est
les sièges sont sont sup partout tout
est sublime vous avez vu l'émission Le
papotant dont on parle beaucoup
c'est le président de la République avec
des journalistes autistes qui lui posent
des questions un peu Président
je vous conseille de regarder c'est
vraiment très bien honnêtement j'en ai
regardé plusieurs déjà
je trouve même ça assez génial encore
une fois c'est un truc nouveau c'est une
de détourner le côté un peu habituel de
l'interview qu'on fait 50 fois on pose
tout le temps les pissons un peu ils
sont très cash j'ai l'impression ils
sont très cash et plus de barrières ça
c'est génial c'est un côté hyper sympa
moi j'avais vu celle avec Gilles
Lellouche que j'aime vraiment beaucoup
j'avais tourné avec lui et dans un film
j'avais adoré c'est un quelqu'un très
très généreux c'est beau hein encore là
aussi force le silence
c'est sûr
c'est très cinématographique pour le
coup c'est Sylvain vous devez être très
content
[Musique]
que ça soit cinq minutes
je voulais rentrer dans le dur à la
tournée un peu autour du pot sur la
polémique du film une polémique autour
de ce film autour de vaincre mourir bien
sûr en ce moment on peut expliquer ce
qui s'est passé
le film est sorti hier il y a une
polémique qui divise les historiens
c'est-à-dire est-ce que vous avez des
noms
j'ai pas de nom précis non parce que
il faut
des trucs comme ça en fait il faut dire
les choses dans leur exactitude alors
non non mais c'est vous qui en parlez
parce que moi honnêtement je vous avoue
que ce qui m'intéresse dans ce film et
les raisons pour lesquelles je les fais
c'est certainement pas ça c'est avant
pas pour créer des polémiques moi c'est
pas quelque chose qui m'intéresse
vraiment ça comme je vous le disais moi
les projets que je choisis c'est parce
que je trouve que il y a une histoire
qui est qui est méconnue on s'intéresse
à quelque chose on va faire un finition
parce que c'est rare de faire des films
scientifiques parce qu'il a une portée
écologique qui me touche parce que voilà
telle pièce de théâtre il y a il y a un
texte voilà on raconte l'histoire sans
abri et que et que c'est un sujet qui me
touche et ben là
les raisons pour les j'ai fait ce film
c'est parce que
[Musique]
c'est une histoire que je ne connaissais
pas et que je trouve que c'était
intéressant de s'intéresser l'histoire
méconnu
libération il y a deux jours deux trois
jours fait une vous êtes
c'est d'ailleurs la photo très belle
photo très belle photo d'ailleurs avec
le titre Le Puy du Fourbe
grande polémique
c'est un sujet dont on ne peut pas
parler est-ce qu'il y a des sujets tout
simplement des sujets tabous et est-ce
que vous vous défendez une cause
incorrecte si je veux dire en faisant ce
film
moi ce que je pense de ce film c'est ce
que je vous disais c'est que il y a dans
ce film là un côté intemporel et
universel c'est l'histoire
d'un peuple d'irréductible qui soulève
contre un pouvoir en place parce que on
vient les chercher on leur demande
d'aller combattre aux frontières de
l'Est pour des combats qui les concerne
pas parce qu'on modifie leurs habitudes
et leurs yeux coutumes le film il est il
est pas du tout manichéen c'est que le
film il est pas en train de dire que la
révolution
c'est pas bien au contraire on en
connaît tous les bienfaits de la
Révolution ça c'est indéniable et
d'ailleurs bien accueilli comme dans
comme c'est exprimé dans le film
simplement
c'est de regarder en arrière et de se
rendre compte voilà qu'il y a des choses
c'est quelque chose qui a été remis au
programme scolaire il y a pas si
longtemps les guerres de Vendée moi
c'est des choses que j'ignorais et je me
dis c'est intéressant de
cette c'est intéressant d'en parler en
fait de dialoguer là-dessus et ça peut
permettre de ne pas reproduire les mêmes
erreurs
à l'avenir
voilà ce que ce que je peux vous dire là
dessus
notamment ce média de gauche qui
vous attaque en tout cas le film est de
faites vous puisque vous portez le film
vous êtes agacé vous êtes énervé vous
dites bah non non je suis pas d'accord
avec ça ou bon ça vous passe au-dessus
honnêtement je sais pas de j'essaie de
pas trop rentrer là-dedans parce que
c'est pas ce qui m'intéresse je trouve
que c'est pas ce qui reste
pas vous en dire plus pour moi c'est
Pascal ce qui ce qui reste c'est c'est
l'aventure humaine qu'on a vécu nous
ce qui reste c'est que c'est un film
historique qui a été
qui je pense fait du bien à beaucoup de
gens et apaise voilà c'est un sujet qui
avait été beaucoup mis de côté etc et
non on l'a bien vu pendant les
projections etc il y a beaucoup de gens
qui sont très touchés qu'on
qu'on aille enfin on a fait un film sur
cette histoire et qu'on reconnaisse
cette histoire et qu'on en parle c'est
une histoire qui avait été abordée comme
je vous ai dit dans 93 de Victor Hugo
chez Dumas chez Balzac donc c'est une
histoire un film moi ce qui
m'intéressait c'était de ce côté
universel et à temporel de suivre des
héros historiques s'intéressait des
héros historiques français que ce soit
pas que ce soit pas un sujet sans au
début
quand on vient vous voir pour vous dire
il y a ce film comment ça se passe on
vous dit le Puy du Fou qui
fait venir des milliers voire des
millions de personnes chaque année fait
un film on sait qu'ils sont les les
dirigeants du Puy du Fou moi j'imagine
un milieu du cinéma un peu corseté on
vous protège vos agents vous dit pas
attention quand vous allez faire ce film
il va peut-être y avoir une polémique
comment ça se passe au début comment
vient vous chercher et comment ça se
déroule pour vous d'ici mais si vous
faites si tout ce que vous faites vous
le faites parce que vous avez peur des
polémiques vous faites rien à mon avis
vous m'avez dit vous-même que le film
vous l'avez trouvé intéressant mais
dites vous-même que vous m'avez trouvé
très bien dans ce film c'est vrai mais
fait des compliments
je mon travail enfin le un film comme ça
un film historique en France c'est assez
rare c'est génial que ce soit pas
exclusivement les Américains ou les
Anglais qui racontent l'histoire de
France donc moi déjà ça c'est une chose
très positive
je suis très heureux qu'on fasse des
films sur notre sur notre histoire il y
a eu des chefs de littérature pourquoi
on servirait pas de ces histoires là qui
sont plus fortes qui sont presque
grecques ou les personnages sont
extrêmement
tourmentées puissants etc et traversent
des choses
qu'on pourrait pas inventer
ça fait des films forts ça fait des
films plein d'émotions et extrêmement
extrêmement puissant où on a besoin de
figure héroïque et en fait il y en a
plein dans l'histoire de France il y en
a plein des deux côtés moi dans ce film
là le personnage qui jouait pas Grégory
Fitoussi qui est le général travaux qui
est mon opposant pour moi c'est un héros
dans ce film c'est un héros c'est
quelqu'un qui a une noblesse d'âme c'est
quelqu'un qui a des valeurs de
combativité tout comme mon personnage
mon personnage d'ailleurs on voit aussi
ses failles dans le film il commet des
exactions il est dit lui-même que qu'il
n'est pas un saint on le voit sombrer un
peu dans une folie dans une obsession
le il y a une phrase de ce film moi qui
me qui pour moi résume tout ce que je
pense pour vous répondre
elle dit la guerre nous apprend à
devenir ce qu'on est pas
voilà pour moi ce film il cherche à
raconter toutes les dérives qui peut y
avoir dans un combat donc l'idée de ce
film elle est pas du tout manichéenne
loin de là en tout cas c'est pas pour
ces raisons là que l'ensemble du casting
est venu que Gilles graines Grégory rode
Anne moi-même non on n'est pas voilà on
est venu sur un film comme ça parce
qu'on était touché par le sujet et
en trouvait que c'est un film qui
pouvait justement réconcilier des gens
avec leur histoire parce que c'est des
gens qui voilà en vendait c'est quelque
chose qui c'est c'est quelque chose de
très très lourd très très lourd et il
faut parler des choses en fait en plus
ça fait 200 plus de 200 ans c'est-à-dire
si on peut pas en parler de façon
apaisée il y a quand même un problème
non je veux dire donc moi c'est pour ces
raisons là que j'y suis allé et ensuite
j'ai rencontré les les réalisateurs ils
avaient interviewé énormément
d'historiens c'est pour ça qu'on vous
dites
il faut aller parler avec Anne Roland
boulestraux avec Jean-Clément Martin
avec ils sont allés voir tous ces gens
là
et nous on a eu accès à tous ces
entretiens qu'ils avaient eus avec eux
et on a bien vu que le film qui a été
écrit a été dans une démarche de
justement s'intéresser uniquement au
fait pas rentrer dans des choses qui
pourraient créer des polémiques la
volonté était l'inverse en fait de tout
faire pour pas pour pas créer ce genre
de polémique et typiquement typiquement
il y a eu dans dans ce film une vraie
volonté de
s'intéresser au fait et aux choses qui
étaient parmi dans toutes les interviews
de ces historiens les choses qui qui
je dirais qui ne faisaient pas débat
justement ou les faits ou qu'elles sur
lesquels tout le monde était d'accord et
on a discuté notamment du fait de ne pas
faire un film
maniché pour moi c'était très important
c'est des choses importantes on en a
discuté longuement donc voilà j'ai deux
petites questions
en sortant du thème du film
je reviens à cette question quand au
début on vient vous voir on vous dit le
Puy du Fou produit un film ce que vous
vous inquiétez est-ce que vous est-ce
qu'on vous dit attention ça va arriver
certains médias vont tomber dessus
est-ce que vous avez pas peur de vous
griller pardon pour le faire mais faut
pas avoir les a prior enfin je sais pas
vous vous avez des a priori sur
moi j'ai l'impression qu'en fait
moi je vais sur vous connaissez
sur un projet comme les acteurs pour les
raisons que je vous ai donné parce que
je suis content de faire un film
historique en France parce que je sais
qu'en France on en fait peu parce que je
trouve que c'est bien qu'on en fasse
tout comme quand je fais un film de
science-fiction je me dis c'est bien de
faire un film de science-fiction quand
je fais une annonce juste avant les
forêts qu'on en fait un plan séquence je
me dis c'est intéressant la démarche est
intéressante et c'est cette diversité là
cette richesse là qui me plaît de me
dire tiens on va faire un truc qui est
intéressant sur un sujet qui est
entre guillemets méconnu pour beaucoup
de gens
donc tout ça ça m'intéresse après le
reste
c'est pas un problème de caméra
on récupère mais le reste c'est pas
[Musique]
c'est pas l'essentiel de tant que on en
a parlé tout à l'heure un film comme
Brévin ce que vous en retenez
est-ce que c'est qui la produit qu'il a
enfin moi je trouve ça très honnête on
s'intéresse à ça c'est le film qui
compte
c'est pas vrai sujet c'est le film qui
compte bref moi ce que j'en retiens
c'est que ça je trouve que des
personnages héroïques on en a besoin ça
fait du bien moi c'est ça que je vois je
vous avoue non que j'ai pas pensé plus
que ça à ce que vous me dites c'était
pas une c'est pas une obsession dans ma
tête c'est pas ce qui m'intéresse ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de me dire il y a un
personnage qui qui transmet une force et
un espoir qui fait du bien on sort
l'infini comme ça quel que soit sa quête
ou son idéal on se dit eh je vais aller
me battre pour pour ce qui me passionne
et moi et ça ça me plaît ça ça me plaît
on y va on y va
ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse un petit
tour dehors je crois qu'on peut aller
sur la terrasse on va essayer de voir si
c'est ouvert
j'aimerais bien le popotin non mais
c'est qui a eu cette idée-là
un journal qui existe depuis très
longtemps ah bon ouais ça existe depuis
d'accord
ça a été produit alors il me semble
aussi que c'est Nakache et Oli Dano qui
produisent qui même sont derrière la
réalisation etc donc c'est qu'il y a une
vraie idée de faire un produit sympa
pour l'instant on peut pas trop aller
voir
ça
c'est bon ça
c'est très bon
comment ça s'est passé au début
de votre carrière vous arrivez est-ce
que ça commence à parler
non ça commence pas à Paris ça commence
enfin si ça commence un peu à Paris
puisque quand j'avais
entre 10 et 12 ans je sais plus
exactement
mon grand-père nous avait offert des
places pour la comédie française et je
me rappelle d'avoir vu
un tampon avec écrit depuis 1680 et je
me disais les mecs sont pote depuis
trois siècles et demi
et je trouvais ça assez fou c'est génial
en fait ce côté troupe moi ça m'a
toujours plu c'est ce que c'est pour ça
que je fais du théâtre c'est aussi pour
ça que il y a des aventures humaines sur
des tournages avec le casting qui sont
qui sont des menthes qui sont vraiment
des des moments assez fous et oui
c'était la Comédie Française ça m'avait
marqué ça de voir depuis 1680 je m'étais
dit
ça ça me plairait en fait de faire
partie de quelque chose qui est un peu
plus grand que que ce soit voilà de se
donner à quelque chose qui est un peu
plus grand que soi ça je trouve ça joli
vraiment et puis les grands textes de
théâtre voilà j'ai très vite découvert
ça et beaucoup de séries du cinéma du
théâtre vous en faites vous avez le
temps d'en faire beaucoup du théâtre
j'ai joué les variations énigmatiques en
décembre par exemple
normalement à Avignon d'ailleurs en
juillet
et non tous les je dirais une fois tous
les deux ans tous les ans et demi
j'essaie de faire une pièce voilà s'il y
a un si un texte qui me qui m'intéresse
c'est un texte que voilà
moi j'adore ça je trouve que c'est un
besoin en fait c'est aussi un besoin je
trouve que c'est un ça donne un
équilibre ça donne un équilibre ça ça
ramène au
fond de notre travail tu vois
au vrai ou vrai au vrai truc c'est que
un film il existe par lui-même une œuvre
comme on a vu elle est contre le mur le
théâtre si je décide on va regarder de
me lever de crier tout ça
oui c'est sûr il y a un respect pour le
théâtre que tu n'as pas besoin d'avoir
dans c'est vrai dans les autres gars
c'est à dire un livre si je veux arrêter
de balancer ça n'arrêtera pas le livre
c'est vrai non c'est vrai qu'il y a bah
c'est un art vivant c'est un art de
l'instant quoi c'est c'est ça qui qui en
fait toute sa beauté c'est son côté
éphémère et en même temps quand vous
allez voir une pièce de théâtre si elle
vous marque vous vous en rappellerez
toutes vos vies le spectacle il est fait
pour vous pour les 200 personnes qui
sont là ça c'est absolument incroyable
on fait ça uniquement pour quelques
personnes qui sont
ça il y a quelque chose de très beau
là-dedans il y a quelqu'un il y a une
communion qui est très belle je trouve
entre entre les gens au cinéma il y a
autre chose qui est sublime c'est que
les choses restent
et on les revoit différemment il y a des
choses qui par exemple 30 ans après vont
avoir une autre vie qui vont devenir un
peu cultes d'autres qui vont devenir
tomber dans l'oubli totalement le
théâtre on le fait pas pour ça ouais on
le fait pour on fait pour l'instant
mais
pour moi pour moi c'est
c'est aussi se plonger dans des textes
et ça ça fait un bien dans des grands
textes qui ont traversé le temps je
trouve ça dingue ça je trouve ça sublime
certaines pièces qui
moi qui m'ont marqué
c'était ça c'était vraiment un rêve
d'enfant de faire du théâtre
quand j'ai joué la première fois
l'opérateur de Metz c'est moi je me suis
dit mais
il y avait quelque chose d'un peu irréel
quelque chose de plus de fierté à ce
moment là que un grand film qui fait des
millions d'entrée
peut-être
c'est pas
[Musique]
c'est pas la même chose c'est quelque
chose de beaucoup plus intime et
personnel en fait quelque chose on se
dit là je fais quelque je fais quelque
chose qui avait du sens pour moi quand
j'étais enfant donc ça ça a plus de
résonance
c'est plus de profondeur que quelque
chose qui a du succès c'est bien c'est
important aussi mais
accomplir ses rêves d'enfants c'est
autre chose c'est quelque chose qui
a une force
émotionnelle intérieure qui qui est pas
comparable ce sentiment là bref je
trouve qu'ici on a un juste milieu dans
entre votre film le catholicisme
Notre-Dame et puis Bastille ici quand
même
c'est vous qui nous emmenez quelque part
maintenant et maintenant on va aller
chez moi parce que c'est bien là vous
nous avez baladé un peu partout mais
ceci dit ici c'est vraiment un lieu
c'est super que on a pu venir ici
vraiment bon vivant bon vivant bon
vivant bonne humeur
attention Sylvain
c'est un restaurant
en fait j'ai fait c'est
tous les tous les films tous les pièces
ou les trucs que tu fais en général ils
ont ils ont une incidence ensuite sur
certaines choses là typiquement je pense
que si vous avez pas fait la série chef
on irait pas chez bons vivants ce soir
et si tu n'avais pas fait un
court-métrage aussi à quelques années
dont le producteur et et un des un des
associés de ce restaurant
si j'avais pas fait ces deux choses là
bon on n'irait pas bon vivant c'est un
lieu de copain déjà c'est un lieu où on
se retrouve
c'est un lieu d'amitié et c'est
d'ailleurs une histoire d'amitié puisque
moi je suis un petit peu associé dans ce
restaurant à petit échelle mais je suis
très heureux de l'aide parce que j'aime
beaucoup l'endroit et
c'est c'est vraiment un truc de pote
c'est à dire que ceux qui l'ont monté ce
sont entouré
que de copains pour
merci
ce sont entourés que de copains
[Musique]
pour pour monter ce si on peut sortir
et là pour le coup ça aurait pu être un
autre film
oui bloqué dans l'image c'est ça
est-ce que je peux enfermer dehors
on m'a dit il y a quelques questions qui
peuvent
un peu l'énerver non mais moi je suis
pas je suis pas un énervé
ça m'a étonné
[Musique]
en fait je me vende de pas grand chose
parce que vous le revendiquez pas quoi
d'avoir fait Gossip Girls aussi est-ce
que on m'a menti tant de ça
je suis comme Julien Doré par exemple
qui l'a fait la nouvelle star mais c'est
quand même un comparable mais
les débuts comme ça moi je suis hyper
fier de le début je vais vous dire je
peux même vous dire que j'ai merci
beaucoup je peux même vous dire que j'ai
fait
ah non mais vous vous rendez compte
j'avais 23 ans je me retrouve à New York
à tourner là-bas c'était c'était
absolument génial c'était vraiment
c'était une expérience de vie de ah non
pour moi c'est c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment quelque chose que j'ai eu une
chance inouïe j'ai vraiment une chance
sinon oui
après moi
honteux qu'on a fait pour démarrer non
pas du tout bon moi je vois pas comme ça
mais en fait
quand vous démarrez quand vous dites je
m'en vonde pas moi je vais pas dans une
interview parler de si ou de ça c'est
c'est
comme si là pendant
je commence à vous raconter par exemple
que en fait c'est quelque chose de très
connu donc forcément comme quelque chose
qui est très connu vous le mettez pas en
avant c'est une question de c'est une
question de pas être c'est une question
d'avoir un peu d'humilité aussi tout
simplement parce que
vous insérez pas le gommet de la
filmographie quoi faut pas rigoler quand
même bah non mais non mais on m'a dit ça
donc mais qui vous a dit ça vous savez
d'autres journalistes qui en discute bon
donc là non pour revendiquer et c'était
de très beaux débuts je sais pas c'est
très beau début je suis passé de
prétention là mais je sais que c'était
une chance inouïe de pouvoir travailler
à l'étranger enfin c'est pour un quand
on sort moi je pensais pas du tout que
j'aurai la chance de travailler
dans des langues étrangères j'ai
travaillé en anglais en espagnol et j'ai
je me retrouve à 23 ans alors que je
pensais faire que du théâtre à la toute
base je me disais je vais faire du
théâtre et ce sera
ouais ce sera simplement
probablement une vie où je vais pas
avoir la chance de de voyager tant que
ça ou de de travailler dans d'autres
langues voilà vous voyez ce que je viens
donc non non non simplement
ah ouais non c'était c'était c'était fou
grâce à ce midi j'ai effectivement j'ai
été
quand vous avez les mirettes j'ai pensé
à Emirates et du coup j'ai pensé à ben
oui parce que j'ai tourné à Emirates
c'était une série pour la BBC et oui on
s'est fait
j'avais déjà j'avais 20 minutes pour
mettre une lucarne
et donc on s'est fait un peu
comment dire
ouais au début impossible
la première était pas la première était
pas bonne du tout c'est je connais un
peu les stades de foot à la mi-temps
quand on voit des gens qui viennent sur
le terrain il faut qu'il réussisse quoi
ils ont on a réussi bon évidemment parce
que le goal a fait ensemble de laisser
passer la balle mais en tout cas elle
est allée dans la bonne direction et là
ils ont ovationné c'était très haut
après j'avais un j'avais trois actions
j'avais ça j'avais un dribble un tacle
et un coup de tête
c'était fou un stade de 70 000 personnes
j'étais hâte de je vous assure alors
attendez attention à ce que vous dites
parce que l'opérateur
de Metz c'est le plus vieux théâtre en
pierre de France ça prouve bien que vous
connaissez pas votre sujet
750 ou 800 places c'est quand même des
ah c'est un très gros théâtre je peux
vous assurer que quand vous jouez sur la
scène de l'opératée à demain ou à la
Comédie des Champs-Élysées ou j'avais
joué
quand vous jouez dans des dans des
endroits comme ça c'est des c'est très
ça c'est impressionnant quand même non
mais c'est sûr que 70000 personnes mais
c'est autre chose parce que ils sont
très loin les gens non et puis déjà et
puis surtout ils sont pas vraiment ils
sont attentifs sans l'être et c'est pas
comme ça
c'est surtout très amusant en fait 70
000 personnes c'est une sensation je
pense que j'aurais jamais pu je faisais
pas ce métier
me retrouver à cet endroit là quoi
mais en même temps que vos questions ne
me fâchent pas moi allez-y
tant mieux j'y vais vous pouvez parler
un peu de me cacher
votre question personne vous a rien dit
et vous dites mais non parce qu'on m'a
dit que peut-être alors là mon avis vous
créez un peu le truc il y a un on m'a
dit allez-y parce que le on m'a dit mais
sans citer on est ce que quand vous
voulez du tout seul
mes amis copains je vais vous dire ce
que je pense que vous vous dites ça vous
vous dites ah il a fait ça il y a 10 ans
c'est sûr on a moins envie de parler des
choses qu'on a fait tout au début on a
envie moi je fais une interview j'ai un
film qui sort j'ai envie de parler du
film qui est en train de sortir ça je
suis d'accord avec vous c'est évident
c'est très logique mais en revanche
franchement on a parlé de vaincrements
en fait je vous parle parce que je suis
de plus dans le présent mais on peut
parler par exemple
on peut parler que de quoi on peut
parler d'autre est-ce qu'on peut parler
de ce que j'ai fait il y a 10 ans
on peut parler de l'assaut
j'avais un mini rôle là-dedans je n'ai
pas parlé non plus non c'est simplement
enfin honnêtement je pense que vous vous
dites ça mais moi en fait je suis je
suis né à Metz dans une famille où je
pouvais que je trouvais que rêver à se
faire ce métier là c'était quelque chose
non pas du tout c'est donc c'était
quelque chose d'assez inaccessible
donc moi j'ai je regarde toutes les
toutes ces choses là comme un parcours
et il y a rien que je enfin tout fait
partie de ce parcours là et je suis très
fier de d'où je viens et de ce parcours
là j'ai pas de gêne du tout du tout du
tout je pense que ça vous vous dites
vous je peux comprendre que vous disiez
ça mais non moi j'ai jamais il y a aucun
aucune des choses que j'ai faite que que
j'assume pas ou je cache rien simplement
c'est vrai que dans chaque interview
j'essaie de parler des dernières choses
parce que l'idée quand même là c'est de
faire la promotion d'un film ou d'une
actualité donc à chaque fois forcément
je parle des choses les plus récentes je
vous ai parlé du dernier voyage pourquoi
parce qu'il y a le film de Romain
Guiraud à pages qui sort le 15 février
et comme on a fait dans les voyageurs
ensemble et que c'est mon pote j'ai
envie que son film il fonctionne j'ai
envie si je peux partir
quand j'ai dit je reçois Hugo Becker il
y aura la nuit affolé est-ce qu'il est
avec quelqu'un
[Rires]
alors ça évidemment je vous répondrai
pas là alors là pour le coup attention
ah oui je peux m'exprimer je peux
m'exprimer très clairement ah les
copains et les copains vous répondez à
cette question je vous répondez pas je
vous réponds que je ne vous répondrai
pas pourquoi il y a plein de vedettes
qui se montrent pas dans ma vie privée
je suis pas là pour ça vous êtes
amoureux ou pas je suis pas là pour ça
et donc vous n'aurez pas de réponse non
non ça j'ai toujours évité je trouve je
trouve ça en fait vous sortez en faisant
ça serait bien en faisant ça en parlant
de ça
ce que font les gens qui parlent de ça
et les journalistes qui s'intéressent un
peu moi je trouve qu'il y a quelque
chose d'un peu voyeuriste un peu un peu
dit un peu
d'accord avec moi mais vous aussi c'est
ça mais moi je suis pas fan de ça
d'accord je vous le dis je suis pas fan
de ça je trouve que c'est dommage parce
que c'est
si on veut intéresser les gens à une
pièce de théâtre à certains sujets etc à
des films
il faut leur parler de ça et là ils vont
s'intéresser il faut qu'on oui mais vous
voyez comment marche le cinéma
s'il avait pas sa relation avec Marion
Castilla
je l'aime beaucoup pour ces films le
reste ça m'intéresse pas du tout mais
est-ce que ça peut mais je trouve que
justement
ça ce que vous êtes en train de faire
bah c'est pas bien parce qu'en fait
finalement pour les gens
je trouve que la vie privée non mais je
trouve que la vie privée je trouve que
les artistes on leur demande quand on
s'intéresser à leur vie privée c'est pas
très simple c'est pas c'est pas la bonne
démarche on fait pas ce métier là pour
être pour exposer nos vies privées pas
du tout on fait ce média pour justement
pour intéresser sur sur un texte sur une
pièce sur un sujet donc jamais je
réponds à la question comme ça parce que
je trouve que c'est un peu le
nivellement par le bas si je sais pas
a pas de raison on va manger ça par
contre ça par contre c'est sympa on y va
[Rires]
je sais pas si mérite que vous serviez
parce qu'il est quand même manger
parfait impeccable enchanté
[Musique]
bonsoir ça va ça va bien
salut ça va et toi bonjour
c'est bien c'est le bordel comme on aime
hein
[Musique]
ça va mon gars
parce que ça fait 1h30 comme ça
du meilleur espoir Molière de la
révélation
j'ai envie de moi j'ai envie de parler
d'un coup
alors comme il y a du bruit ce que je
vais faire c'est que je vais mettre un
micro quand même
alors tu veux que je lui donne le mien
non non on va rester ensemble bon
vaincre trop mourir grand projet quoi
comment ça se passe depuis 3 jours là
bah écoute on est super content c'est
plutôt positif pour l'instant
en vrai
on est un peu choqué de
comment a été un peu reçu le film mais
on pense que on pense que ça va le faire
et nous on est content de défendre cette
histoire et on a passé au moins en tout
cas j'ai j'ai passé 18 jours de dingue
en plus des deux semaines de répétition
avec son amantage pas la prendre à ne
pas être avec Hugo et tout ça enfin
l'épée et tout ça a été vraiment dingue
et inspirant déjà de le voir aussi
travailler comme ça parce que lui il est
hyper à l'aise à cheval et j'ai été
c'était vraiment étonné son quand il
était vraiment le mec c'était
directement charrette quoi je suis
arrivé j'ai fait ah ouais ok d'accord
bon bah va falloir que je me mette au
boulot là ouais mais tu as fait toutes
les cascades au final
mais du coup c'est bien ça m'a motivé on
était une super équipe les filles les
Amazones elles étaient super on a
ensemble on a bossé avec des gars que
j'ai envie de citer parce que William
est mixage Maxime ils ont formé ils
étaient super avec nous en fait c'est
les cascadeurs
si tu veux qu'on chorégraphié toutes les
cascades de Vincent alors après ils les
ont pas fait les cascades il m'a dit que
vous aviez tout fait vous
en fait c'est nous super formateur ils
ont fait aussi ils ont fait des Bleus
ils ont fait ils ont ils ont joué comme
souvent dans les films des cascadeurs
souvent sont dans les scènes etc parce
que ça va permettre de régler les scènes
et généralement quand tu fais une scène
de baston et qui distribue des des
patates en général le plus important
c'est le mec qui la reçoit toi tu es
hyper content de ton truc mais en fait
c'est le mec qui la reçoit mal on y
croit pas c'est lui c'est lui qui rend
la sainte crédule c'est ça
qui peut vraiment partir
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pose la caméra viens manger un truc
c'est pas il va poser la question je
sais mais non est-ce que est-ce que vous
aimez la viande et ben ici la viande
je pouvais pas vous rater si vous prenez
une côte de beurre ou un filet de bœuf
ou une entrecôte voilà pourquoi le
poisson c'est bien aussi il y a des
trucs il y a des plats végétariens il y
a un risotto végétarien il y a tout
vous prenez quoi vous moi je pense que
je vais prendre un poisson très bon pour
la mémoire et
que et qu'on a fait pas mal en fait hier
on a un peu on a un peu fêté hier parce
qu'on a quand même beaucoup travaillé
c'est ce que on voit c'est selon qu'on
parle pas on parle pas les gens se
rendent pas compte mais il y a le
tournage et la préparation c'est souvent
beaucoup plus rare que ton âge jumelle
et après le tournage la promo les
avant-première et donc à un moment donné
tu es content aussi de de fêter un peu
voilà
je suis déjà tombé sur des films
avec des comédiens qui n'aiment pas
faire de la promo et nous et nous on
était tous là et on a on a tous été là
pour défendre le film Hugo est parti
avec Vincent Mottet le second
réalisateur dans toute la province nous
on a été on a essayé d'être là sur Paris
et cetera chacun a essayé d'aller
partout et franchement je trouve ça
remarquable parce qu'en fait on est tout
cela défend ce film et c'est hyper cool
en fait donc c'était plus en ce moment
Apache aussi ouais c'est vrai
effectivement euh on le voit plus que
vous dansez donc bien sûr mais moi je
fais vraiment une apparition c'est un
clin d'oeil parce que j'avais très belle
c'est gentil mais c'est c'est Rhodes
c'est Nil c'est Alice
il y a Arthur
il y a beaucoup de personnes franchement
c'est cool on a on a c'est une belle
expérience aussi je suis super content
d'avoir ces deux films en fait qui me
qui me propulse totalement ailleurs de
de ce que j'ai pu faire en fait
deux films d'époque
qui sont définis qui sont très rarement
en France donc et donc ça ça me fait
vraiment kiffé en fait on est sur deux
réalisateurs qui sont dans des veines
qui sont hyper cool en fait non c'est
vrai
pour un acteur c'est ce qu'il y a de
plus marrant c'est cool
d'être dans des univers qui ont rien à
voir il fait un film sur le gang des
Apaches
il est revenu sur les guerres de Vendée
c'est quand même alors voilà
parce que c'est cool de faire la tête
haute ouais mais
voilà c'est c'est cool de faire la tête
ce genre de film d'auteur et cetera mais
c'est hyper intéressant pour un comédien
de faire des rôles
dans lequel tu sais que tu vas incarner
un personnage qui a existé qui a une
force de ventre de vivre de faire les
choses d'exister de de d'essayer hyper
cool en fait c'est hyper cool c'est
totalement différent qu'un film d'auteur
ou tu vas jouer un enfant qui en
difficulté avec une famille c'est alors
c'est des difficultés aussi pour le pour
le rôle par exemple pour prudent de la
rubrique c'est il va montrer jusqu'au
bout qu'il est fidèle justement à
charrette donc c'est il y a ça aussi
dans le signe il y a plein de il y a
plein de choses c'est pour ça que pour
nous effectivement
tout ce qui est polémique vous intéresse
pas vraiment ou quand tu me dis mais
est-ce que vous êtes pas dit que si vous
ça non pas vraiment et on a quand même
le sentiment qu'il y a un lourd procès
d'intention
la démarche elle était vraiment
pas parce qu'il y avait des voilà il y a
des valeurs de fidélité qui sont belles
dans le film alors de combativité de
dépassement de soi c'est aussi ça un
film c'est aussi les valeurs que tu
communiques toi tu fais un film pas de
d'horreur extrêmement gore etc bah là
les valeurs vont c'est un peu compliqué
quand même dans ce film là il y a quand
même beaucoup de choses
c'est pas moi de le respect tu vois
entre travaux et j'arrête il y a toutes
ces choses là en fait et c'est pour ça
que
[Musique]
ce qui est polémique moi m'intéresse pas
des masses parce que je trouve que ça ça
aucune en fait ce qui est vraiment dans
le film ce qui est vraiment vigne et ce
qui est vraiment la démarche qu'on a
tous eu par rapport à ça on sait pas
poser les on sait pas du tout posé les
questions que vous vous posez ou que
vous vous nous posez c'est pas posé on a
en fait on n'a pas c'est à dire que
quand tu vois pas on voit pas les choses
forcément de la même
et la même façon moi j'ai vraiment
l'impression que c'est c'est assez
surprenant parce que c'est le le on
tombe dans quelque chose
mais moi je regarde pas
des réalisateurs dire dans le monde du
cinéma vous faites pas ici par exemple
vous savez très bien que il va se passer
j'aimerais répondre à ça c'est par
exemple moi quand je suis comédien et
que et que je regarderai réalisateur en
fait je lui ai un scénario je vais pas
je vais pas moi je pense c'est même pas
forcément
ment cette position
je suis hyper touché par le sujet je
vais je vais défendre une histoire qui a
existé
et surtout que moi quand je regarde le
film je l'ai vu tout maintenant trois
fois quand je regarde le film et que je
sors de la salle j'ai qu'une envie c'est
d'embrasser mon d'embrasser mon prochain
et d'être soudé avec le peuple en fait
parce qu'à la fin justement la scène de
fin en fait quand on regarde le film les
deux se respectent et c'est limite si il
sert la main en fait et il y a un truc
très honorable et ils savent pourquoi
tous les deux il se respecte en fait et
qu'on a beau avoir des avis différents
chaque personne chaque humain chaque
machin à un moment donné on est tous
fait pour être pour exister ensemble et
et se donner de l'amour c'est le
meilleur c'est pas la guerre qui va
faire les choses c'est l'amour
[Musique]
parce que tu vois c'est ça que vous
voyez c'est nous c'est ça qu'on a retenu
quand on a plus projet entre les mains
une polémique l'inverse la
réconciliation donc les gens disent oui
mais vous savez il va y avoir une
polémique
les gens diront c'est où ça mais le film
lui-même est-ce que est-ce qu'il
qu'est-ce qu'il raconte est-ce que s'il
raconte est dérangeant bah nous on le
voit pas du tout comme un film manichéen
on a l'impression que c'est vraiment tu
fais pas du cinéma pour faire de la
politique
un parcours un peu différent parce que
vous Hugo
il y a un truc qui est drôle d'ailleurs
avec grande on a un parcours différent
mais moi la première fois que je l'ai vu
c'était sur scène à la Comédie des
Champs-Élysées on parlait peut-être tout
à l'heure et jouer l'Office il était
incroyable ouais qui vient de sortir
justement the sun
et j'étais avant parce que juste après
vous ouvrez le cahier de Einstein dans
le même théâtre donc on a joué on s'est
croisé une ou deux fois comme ça
et aujourd'hui effectivement on a fait
deux dimensions
j'ai une famille qui est vraiment loin
de ça j'ai juste un nom qui m'a toujours
montré la culture de Belmondo de de
plein de personnes des des grandes
comédie des choses comme ça mais j'ai
jamais eu l'accessibilité même dans mon
cerveau juste de me dire un jour je
pourrais faire du cinéma en fait je
savais pas qu'on pouvait devenir acteur
en fait
moi je voyais des films j'étais blue et
c'est tout en fait et à un moment donné
je suis tombé sur Elda Pharaon qui m'a
qui m'a qui m'a qui faisait du casting
sauvage au lycée de Gennevilliers
j'étais en cap de menuiserie justement
une belle table en bois donc voilà
elle est passée
ça me donne envie de toucher le bois et
de me dire que le peuple va vouloir
aller le voir ce film parce qu'en fait
il y a que de l'amour c'est pas c'est
pas un truc tu vois mais bref pour
revenir à l'histoire c'est que je suis
obligé de la chance en fait je suis
tombé sur sur un cas ouais et c'est vrai
que ça m'a donné envie
elle est venue vous voir on dit en fait
elle est venue me voir elle m'a dit
voilà ton profil correspond pour euh en
fait je dirais assez présenté on a dit
je suis directrice de casting travaille
sur un film en ce moment elle m'a pas
trop dit les comédiens et cetera la
médiatrice et on a fait des essais dans
une salle de classe j'ai été rappelé
j'ai été au boulevard Sébastopol à Paris
et en fait je suis arrivé dans une salle
où on s'est retrouvé à 30 40 je me suis
dit mais je vais jamais l'avoir le rôle
et j'ai tenté le truc et en fait on me
rappelait on peut appeler on me
rappelait et j'ai dû faire au moins
franchement je pense que je mens quand
c'est ça mais j'ai fait au moins 40 et 7
différents pour le 1 je te jure j'avais
rencontré Alexandra Lamy pour Sarah
forestier j'avais en fait quand j'ai
commencé à rencontrer des comédiens un
peu déjà comme ça parce que c'est du bon
on est plus haut niveau du rôle de
Maloni on est plus au niveau de test à
la chérie qui est aussi faisait que si
vous sauvage et donc c'est euh voilà
Diane ro
et en fait à force de voir les grands
comédiens
je fais pas des essais comme ça juste
pour machin et en fait elle m'a dit si
tu as ton cap je te prends est-ce que ce
qui s'est passé c'est que j'ai pas eu
mon cap mais j'ai demandé au lycée de me
dire le truc
et du coup ça joue à quoi derrière et du
coup
mais je pense qu'elle m'aurait pris même
c'est énorme mais je suis super content
et après j'ai rencontré Catherine
Deneuve aux essais
j'ai envie de devenir comédien quand tu
sors du tournage et en même temps ça a
été quand même un tournage très intense
très dur parce qu'en fait pendant trois
mois tu tournes avec tout le monde c'est
une famille et tu joues au lendemain il
y a plus personne
pas comme si on va trop mourir là on est
tous ensemble donc on a envie de
travailler ensemble
et mais voilà mais en tout cas oui c'est
c'est bien quand tu as 18 ans et que tu
passes trois mois avec tout le monde et
que tu reviens chez toi et que tu
travailles au McDo et après tu te
retrouves à Cannes au bout de 6 mois tu
dis qui se passe quoi c'est clair et
après tu dis bon vas-y j'ai envie de
faire ça et toute façon je saurais pas
je sais pas ce que j'aimerais faire
d'autre et j'adore ce métier là et moi
je fais pas ce métier là pour parler de
politique je vais se mettre là pour vous
donner de l'amour et en recevoir aussi
parce qu'en fait quand je vois un roule
bah je passe d'émotions en émotion et ça
me ça me procure des choses ça me soigne
même parfois quand tu as du désarroi
dans la vie bah tu te Soignes en joie ou
c'est ce qu'on disait clairement mais
c'est marrant parce que c'est en fait
c'est du bon sens c'est vrai c'est ce
que tu dis quoi c'est que c'est c'est
ce que je te dis tout à l'heure il y a
un côté dans les dans les films il y a
un côté où l'histoire finalement c'est
un prétexte pour véhiculer des émotions
et
il est bon lui il est bon il est mûr
effectivement ça te donne moi je crois
que j'ai voulu faire ce métier là parce
que j'avais envie de faire les métiers à
chaque fois de de chaque film tu vois
Top Gun dans le pilote de chasse tu vois
ce que génial et et il y a et en fait tu
te rends compte assez vite que
c'est le métier il est c'est pas ça qui
est important mais c'est ce que tu aimes
chez certains personnages c'est qu'en
fait il t'emmène il transporte de
l'énergie en fait
la vie elle est quand même elle est
parsemée de des profs tout le monde tout
le temps on prend tous des claques dans
la tronche tout le temps et les films et
les livres et les musiques souvent c'est
des choses qui donnent de la force tu
vas écouter une musique regarde mes
musiques où il y a beaucoup de gens
connaissent enfin ils comprennent pas
forcément les paroles parce qu'elle te
donne elle te donne bien sûr et il y a
et
faut pas oublier ça et je pense que
tu regardes ça tu comprends pourquoi
beaucoup de choses ont été faites et
c'était souvent pour ces raisons là et
souvent quand tu vas sur un film c'est
aussi pour ces raisons là maintenant la
suite vous avez des petites questions
vas-y 2 de d'amateur de cinéma on mange
un truc ou pas est-ce qu'on mange un
truc est-ce qu'on peut manger un truc
vous avez envie de toi moi je sais pas
qu'est-ce que tu nous crois qu'est-ce
que tu nous confondues
circuit de fromage ça appartient en
entrecôte là partage alors
un petit peu
pourquoi pas je vous mets une autre côté
et après
il est bientôt minuit
j'adore
du coup l'histoire de resto oui enfin
tout à l'heure quand on est acteur on a
des modèles c'est qui le modèle pour
chacun d'entre vous
[Musique]
[Rires]
le mec
racine si vous a le plus impressionné et
ce bien avec qui vous aimeriez te voir
c'est pas facile c'est pas facile ta
question
pendant longtemps c'était Édouard Norton
on a le plus impressionné
et avec qui j'aimerais tourner et qui
m'impressionne aussi énormément c'est
Denzel Washington je suis absolument fan
de nos réseaux sociaux c'est vrai je te
donne mais j'aurais pu dire Benoît
Magimel ok non c'est marrant parce que
je viens de finir de plus en plus
il est incroyable dans deux sont vivants
la meilleure acteur moi j'ai franchement
j'ai pris une claque et encore une fois
c'est Berco
le seul qui vous êtes j'adore j'adore en
fait il y en a un vraiment que ce qui
était mon idole grâce à mon nom c'est
Jean-Paul Belmondo après c'était un
univers c'était un genre c'était voilà
c'était une époque et en tout cas moi il
m'a beaucoup
[Musique]
c'est le syndicat des acteurs en France
et en avec le Festival de Cannes etc la
Dany finance une opération pour faire
découvrir des nouveaux des nouveaux
talents moi je l'ai fait j'ai été talent
talent Canada nuit en 2010 quand je suis
sortie d'école c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui t'aide qui était victime qui
permet de rencontrer des directeurs de
casting etc cette année il y a eu 1600
je sais plus combien candidature et et
et ils m'ont proposé j'étais très honoré
depuis ça de réaliser un des films ils
font bon ils prennent quatre
réalisateurs et leur demande de réaliser
un court-métrage et du coup il casse
parmi toutes ces candidatures trois
acteurs pour pour les mettre en avant et
pour que voilà que que le film soit vu
au festival ça permettra ce qui est
diffusé à Cannes
qui a diffusé à Clermont car pas mal de
festival tester en partenariat avec
France 2 aussi c'est une assez grosse
opérations
[Musique]
mais oui c'est un court-métrage mais ça
me plaît beaucoup j'adore ça génial
travailler les acteurs c'est vraiment ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui me
plaît vous me montrez vos talents de son
comment
on peut aller je sais pas si je vais
vous montrer mais je peux vous raconter
un peu le temps en cuisine
on peut aller en cuisine ou pas
viens avec nous si jamais vu en plus tu
cuisines bien toi moi c'est moi qui
cuisine à la maison c'est vrai en plus
de rester collé
ce que j'ai vu je me suis dit je vais
mettre le HF dans la peau
petite on
est là ça va bonjour ça va salut
les gars bon alors on va venir vous
emmerder on va venir vous on va venir
vous emmerder
voilà alors bon il y a tout ce qui est
tout ce qui est crème au lait
il y a tout ce qui est côte de bœuf et
tout ce qui est poivre en sel moutarde
moelleux au chocolat
la cuisine la cuisine est un peu petite
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que on a
j'ai fait une série chef où j'étais à la
d'ailleurs à la plonge pendant très
longtemps dans cette série au début que
tu as vu pierre
et j'ai appris la découpe j'ai vraiment
j'ai appris à découper en julienne en
Brunoy
qui va arriver juste maintenant il y a
eu Hugo qui va nous lever les filets je
vais lever les filets
lever les filles bien sûr
honnêtement on apprend énormément de
choses pour ton acteur et c'était assez
dingue parce que j'ai bossé avec David
Toutain c'est David Toutain qui
aujourd'hui un restaurant il y avait
Clovis Cornillac qui était coacher par
Thierry Marx et moi par David Toutain et
on a appris énormément de choses donc
c'est vrai qu'on Ludo qui a un autre
copain à nous à ma présenté ce bon
vivant à droite qui s'appelle qui
s'appelle Pierre Mouquet
et qu'ils ont monté et qu'ils ont monté
bon vivant moi j'avais très envie de
faire partie de l'aventure donc elle m'a
toute petite échelle c'est c'est eux les
patrons mais c'est un truc de copain
donc c'est sympa et c'est vrai que ce
cette série ça m'a fait adorer ce monde
là c'est un monde c'est un monde dur
quand même c'est un monde dur mais faut
bosser mais mais il y a un truc
passionnant un truc passionnant et puis
sympa surtout voilà
elle a l'air belle non elle a l'air
sympa je pense que ça va être très
solide
il y a rien de pire que d'emmerder les
gens qui travaillent
pour les individualité bon courage les
gars bon courage bon courage
en fait je suis attaché comme un petit
chien
c'est vrai que
c'était j'avais
je devais apprendre à enlever les
pyjamas de lapin on appelle ça enlever
le pyjama dans la fin fais
et c'était assez génial j'ai vidé un
sanglier je me rappelle encore
il faut pas attraper comme tu veux parce
que si jamais tu te rates tu peux tomber
dans les pommes
l'odeur là c'est
costaud maintenant c'est pas c'est pas
léger comme truc c'est vraiment c'était
et moi j'avais en tournant alors
il y a une scène un sanglier c'est moi
qui le fait
particulier
mais en fait c'est très c'est bizarre et
en même temps c'est complètement
décorrélé c'est-à-dire que tu fais tu
fais les choses mais c'est mécanique en
fait tu as l'impression de faire le truc
mécaniquement tu te rends pas vraiment
compte de ce que tu es en train de tu te
dis pas je suis en train d'ouvrir
5 si je me rate je vais pas non mais ici
il y a quand même pression on va pas se
mentir il a même une grosse notion parce
que si tu si tu rates bah c'est
compliqué ouais on va pas ouais c'est
compliqué après on est dans un abattoir
on a fait en sorte de le faire sur un
sanglier ou ça devait être fait de toute
façon c'est c'est pas quelque chose qui
est fait à la légère c'est un truc très
attention à ce qu'ils font et à comment
comment c'est fait mais oui tu peux pas
le faire de façon
donc et puis tu as envie de le faire
bien aussi parce que tu as envie que ton
personnage soit un peu crédible même si
dans la série mon personnage c'est
quelqu'un qui découvre la cuisine selon
là donc tu démarres comme quelqu'un qui
connaît rien donc au final il devient au
fur et à mesure quelqu'un ici que il se
révèle à il se révèle à sa passion et à
son talent
la dent mais à la base il a pas
forcément les connaissances techniques
donc il est il peut être il peut être
très un grand chef sans forcément être
très fort pour vider un sandwich mais en
l'occurrence il fallait à ce moment là
que ce soit fait comme correctement vous
avez toujours fais ce que vous voulez
jouer maintenant on n'a pas toujours
mais non mais là où tu as raison là où
vous avez raison moi je on a une chance
inouïe
[Musique]
c'est quand même génial de pouvoir faire
d'être dans les univers et dans des
rôles qui ont rien à voir c'est fou
c'est fou
une pilote de course tu as pas encore
fait il se dit non effectivement non il
y a plein de choses
j'aimerais bien jouer un militaire
en tout cas il y a un code d'honneur
c'est vrai ouais c'est vrai mais
vraiment tu vois ce que tu es en
parachute des trucs d'extrême un peu
aussi on peut faire ça ensemble
la promo c'est c'est nécessaire et
important de le faire mais
au bout d'un moment c'est un peu
fatiguant aussi parce qu'en fait tu
répètes les mêmes choses typiquement il
y a certaines questions sur sur ton
personnage etc qui reviennent mais c'est
bien on est pas trop on a pas forcément
les mêmes discussions c'est vrai que
c'est parfois un exercice un peu
difficile c'est dur parce qu'il faut il
faut garder de la fraîcheur il faut
rester toute la journée la même chose
par exemple il faut rester passionnés le
plus important c'est de jamais être
écœuré parce que tu fais s'il ne faut
pas que tu te répètes toute la journée
tu as l'impression d'être écoeuré
honnêtement là je me suis je me suis dit
ce que nous on fait pas c'est pas un
énorme film je me dis mais ceux qui ont
deux mois deux mois de promo
je sais pas comment il faut parfois on
n'a pas envie de commencer on est déjà
arrivé
moi je défends tout sauf que il faut
toujours aller jusqu'au bout des choses
tu vas sur le film
j'imagine que dans votre filmographie
[Musique]
mais tu peux tu t'es pas obligé de dire
que tu as fait le meilleur film du monde
donc on me demande on me demande le plus
mauvais waouh j'ai jamais pensé comme ça
je pourrais le meilleur tiens le
meilleur ça c'est positif
c'est peut-être la nuit juste avant le
forêt parce que il est complètement
atypique il a rien à voir qu'il a été
fait pas du tout dans un but commercial
peut-être même si c'est un c'est un
objet cinématographique
[Musique]
après je regarde pour moi et un peu de
fromage pour pour le calcium je vous
ramène du pain et et un bon verre d'eau
pour aller à la merci
ouais c'est vrai que ce la Mustang
je devrais te dire un truc plus
classique mais en fait celui-là il me
mais toi quand tu fais quand tu dis ça
c'est en terme de quoi en terme
d'expérience en terme de rôle en terme
de bah c'est un peu cumulé de tout ça
c'est de la démarche dans laquelle on
l'a fait
c'est ce que le film raconte c'est ce
que moi j'ai ressenti c'est ce que moi
j'ai trouvé aussi et compris en tant
qu'acteur sur ce film j'ai compris des
choses vous avez pas compris avant j'ai
trouvé tu vois ça m'a déclenché c'est un
peu tout ça et surtout le le destin du
film qui finalement alors qu'il est pas
du tout destiné à avoir une vie
quelconque qui finit par être sur la
plateforme de la Cinémathèque et et à
générer il y a des gens Isabelle Adjani
elle en a parlé de ce film alors là je
peux te dire que quand elle m'a dit ça
elle va pas aller vivre je me suis dit
ça fait parce que c'est quelqu'un de
très curieux qui s'intéresse au théâtre
elle s'est dit tiens ils ont adapté
voilà c'est ça
moi je crois que c'est le théâtre
donc en fait j'ai adoré être
pour un acteur bah tu joues quand même
au théâtre il y a des choses qui sont
tellement différents dans le ressenti
des choses d'avoir un public proche qui
t'écoute que tu sens un peu pleurer un
peu être surpris
l'énergie vitale avec les comédiens sur
scène l'énergie que tu as sur les Comé
sur scène avec les comédiens j'ai trouvé
ça extraordinaire
tous les soirs
donc en fait je peux te dire qu'en terme
d'émotion j'ai jamais été aussi
nos métiers c'est il y a il y a ça en
fait qui est fou c'est le l'adrénaline
que ça te procure un peu
ce que j'ai adoré dans ce projet là
c'est l'écriture de Florent Zeller parce
qu'en fait on avait il y avait plus
enfin tout était là en fait il y a qu'on
avait plus besoin de chercher
à avoir des clés tu vois ce que je veux
dire en fait c'était tellement bien
écrit tellement bien fait que on est
très fort hein
je vous remercie nos internautes qui
nous regardez merci beaucoup de nous
avoir regardé merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup d'avoir passé ce temps-là avec
nous on espère qu'on était on était pas
très chiant
j'espère que tu es pas trop cher et que
nous on continue comment nous on
continue on à table on prend vraiment ça
marche
et bon appétit à ceux qui ont pas encore
dîner du coup
c'est à mon avis il faut tu vois c'est
quoi dessous là une
petite ferme alors en dessous
donc je fais du
chouette petite émulsion en dessous
tu vois un film une pièce